discussion et les résultats obtenus au
regard des objectifs du fond cette
mission d'information a obtenu du Sénat
de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquêtes nous entendons
donc ce matin dans ce cadre monsieur
Sébastien Jallet préfet de l'Orne en sa
qualité d'anciens directeurs de cabinet
de Madame Marlène Schiappa ministre
délégué auprès du ministre de
l'Intérieur chargé de la citoyenneté
comme vous le savez nous avons entendu
ces dernières semaines le secrétaire
général du cipdr monsieur Christian
Gravel ainsi que les représentants de
plusieurs associations ayant bénéficié
des crédits du fond Marianne nous
attendons donc de votre audition que
vous puissiez nous préciser la manière
dont à vos fonctions vous avez suivi ce
dossier en lien d'une part avec la
ministre et d'autre part avec les
services ministériels avant de vous
céder la parole pour un bref propos
introductif on s'est mis d'accord comme
vous êtes seul sur une dizaine de
minutes maximum je dois vous rappeler
qu'un faux témoignage devant une
commission d'enquête et passible de
sanctions pénales qui peuvent aller
selon les circonstances de 3 à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 à 100.000
euros d'amende
je vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levez la main droite et dites je le jure
je le jure
je vous laisse maintenant Monsieur le
Préfet la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le
rapporteurs je remercie la commission de
m'entendre aujourd'hui et nous donner
l'occasion d'apporter ma part
d'explication aux questions
intéressantes la gestion du fond
Marianne j'ai été auditionné par la
mission de contrôle de l'inspection
géant de l'administration diligentée par
le ministère de l'Intérieur
je serai logiquement entendu dans le cas
de l'information judiciaire ouverte par
le parquet national financier j'ai été
sollicité par les médias et je n'ai pas
souhaité y donner suite réservant mes
réponses aux organismes et institutions
saisies
cette audition par votre commission
d'enquête revêt donc pour moi
l'importance particulière car elle est
sans doute la seule occasion qui me soit
donnée de tenir une parole publique sur
le fond Marianne et plus globalement sur
le sens et les modalités du contre
discours républicain
la mise en oeuvre avec les
administrations placées sous l'autorité
de la ministre remise à sa disposition
qui était diverses
et j'assurais une fonction de liaison
avec les autres ministères et avec
Matignon sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
j'étais au sein du cabinet le seul à
bénéficier d'une délégation de
signatures de la ministre déléguée et
donc le seul à pouvoir
valablement légalement juridiquement
engagé la décision ministérielle dans un
rapport de loyauté et de confiance entre
la ministre et moi-même
cette fonction générale de coordination
je l'exercer sur l'ensemble des champs
relevant des attributions de la ministre
délégués elle était en charge d'un
ministère nouvellement créé le ministère
délégué à la citoyenneté auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur avec des
attributions
importantes et d'une grande diversité il
me paraît important de les mentionner en
quelques en quelques termes ces
attributions recouvraient
schématiquement deux grands domaines
tout d'abord la protection des Français
avec les attributions confiées à la
ministre déléguée pour la prévention de
la délinquance pour la prévention de la
radicalisation la lutte contre la dérive
sectaire
la mise en oeuvre des engagements du
Grenoble des violences conjugales pour
ce qui concerne l'action des forces de
sécurité intérieure lutte contre le
séparatisme
la deuxième ligue de force dans les
attributions de la ministre avait très à
aux valeurs de la République avec la
promotion de l'engagement citoyen la
politique de l'asile et d'accueil des
réfugiés la politique de l'intégration
naturalisation le déploiement de la
nouvelle carte nationale d'identité
électronique et le portage
interministériel de la laïcité
j'étais en tant que directeur de cabinet
en charge de préparer et d'exécuter les
décisions de la ministre sous l'ensemble
de ces de ces champs et je m'attachais à
et je m'attacher à y accorder une
importance égale
quel que soit les sujets les dossiers
j'ai ainsi naturellement été en prise
avec la mise en place d'une action
nouvelle de contre des cours
républicains et avec la mise la mise en
place du fond du fond Marianne
je souhaiterais avant de répondre à vos
questions pouvoir replacer en quelques
mots cette démarche dans son dans son
contexte
ce contexte c'est d'abord la veille dans
un terroriste qui frappe le pays à
l'automne 2020 avec le 25 septembre
l'attentat de la rue Nicolas Appert
devant l'ancien siège de Charlie Hebdo
l'attentat d'eragny-sur-oise le 16
octobre 2020
l'attentat la basilique de Nice le 27 le
29 octobre 2020 et ses attentats placent
plus que jamais les pouvoirs publics
dans une ardente obligation d'agir et de
protéger dans tous les domaines
ce contexte c'est donc aussi celui d'une
mobilisation générale contre la haine en
ligne contre le cyber islamisme contre
les idées séparatistes sur Internet
lesquels portent en germe chez certains
individus des risques de bascule dans la
radicalisation et la violence terroriste
la création du fond Marianne s'inscrit
dans ce contexte et n'est que l'un des
éléments d'une stratégie d'ensemble
arrêtée en conseil de défense et de
sécurité nationale à l'automne 2020 et
qui se déploie dans plusieurs directions
il y a d'abord le renforcement de la
plateforme dite Pharos opéré par des
policiers et des gendarmes de la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire une plateforme qui traite les
signalements de contenu à licite sur sur
internet pour à la fois imprimer les
auteurs et demander le retrait de ces
contenus auprès des opérateurs idée et
le ministre de l'Intérieur la ministre
délégué mettre en place le dispositif de
renforcer sensiblement la plateforme
Pharos en portant ses effectifs de 30
policiers gendarmes à 54 en quelques
mois pour assurer un fonctionnement H24
c'est à dire 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 il renforcer la capacité à
judiciariser les contenus haineux
illicitent sur Internet on obtient le
retrait auprès des opérateurs
adoptées dans la loi confortant le
respect des principes de la République
pour tout d'abord
renforcer les obligations des
plateformes dans la suppression des
sites du miroirs des sites qui
répliquent les contenus interdits par la
justice
les plateformes devant désormais assuré
leur effacement véritable ainsi que le
des référencement de ces de ces sites
c'est aussi le principe de la
comparation immédiate introduite par la
loi pour les auteurs d'attraction les
plus graves en matière de n en ligne tel
que de négationnisme
ou d'incitation à la haleine et à la
violence
c'est aussi une disposition de loi qui
crée un délit de mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui par diffusion
d'informations personnelles sur Internet
dans la tension de nuire en référence
direct aux agissements dont ont été
victime
plusieurs plusieurs personnes et le
professeur de consente Honorine en
particulier avec un délit puni de 3 ans
d'emprisonnement 45000 euros d'amende et
des sanctions qui sont majorées si elles
touchent une personne dépositote des
postale de l'autorité publique ou
chargée d'une mission de service public
cette stratégie c'est une mobilisation
au niveau communautaire pour renforcer
la législation européenne avec
l'adoption du règlement dit TCO contre
les contenus terroristes en 2021 qui
oblige l'état de forme à supprimer en
moins d'une heure les contenus un
caractère terroriste ou les efforts
déployés par la France pour promouvoir
le projet directive digital service et
c'est aussi cette stratégie la mise en
place d'une action nouvelle de
contrediscours républicain il y a bien
une stratégie d'ensemble laquelle sera
d'ailleurs
érigée au rang de réforme prioritaire du
gouvernement à la fin de 2020 elle fait
partie des 73 réformes prioritaires du
gouvernement elle est confiée aux
ministres de l'Intérieur à la ministre
délégué en termes de coordination même
si elle associe d'autres ministères je
pense à la Chancellerie mais c'est juste
en particulier
au ministère chargé du numérique et les
ministres seront amenés régulièrement à
rendre compte de l'avancement de cette
stratégie en conseil des ministres ce
sera notamment le 12 janvier 2022 avec
une communication sur les réformes
prioritaires du ministère d'intérieur
dans laquelle la ministre déléguée
des avancées des progrès des enjeux en
matière du contrôle en ligne et le et le
cyber islamisme merci Monsieur le Préfet
si vous voulez bien qu'on en reste là je
pense qu'à l'occasion les
questionnements qui vont venir vous
aurez l'occasion éventuellement de
repréciser quelques points merci de nous
avoir fait en tout cas un rappel
utile sur à la fois le contexte que nous
connaissions de manière générale si je
puis dire mais en rappelant que la
création de ce format donc fait partie
d'une stratégie plus globale ce que vous
présentez ce matin merci beaucoup
nous en venons pour notre part nous
restons vous connaissez évidemment le
rôle de notre mission et elle est
aujourd'hui cernée sur l'élaboration
d'abord dans un premier temps du fond
Marianne donc vous nous avez décrit le
contexte général le fait que le fond
Marianne est un élément parmi d'autres
ce que nous comprenons bien
le fond Marianne et ces quelques moyens
et même le sujet même ne peuvent seul à
lui seul en tout cas répondre à une
question aussi large que celle que vous
avez rappelé mais plus spécifiquement
pouvez-vous nous dire d'où vient l'idée
finalement de mettre en place ce fond et
qui a l'idée de l'appeler pour Marianne
et finalement d'en faire un lien avec
le professeur assassiné
oui
[Musique]
la création du fond Brian s'inscrit dans
ce dans ce contexte et dans ce cadre
dès l'automne 2020 il est donc acté par
les instances compétentes la mise en
place d'une action de contrediscours
contre discours républicain pardon juste
les instances compétentes alors je
faisais référence aux conseils de
défense et de sécurité nationale qui a
adopté la stratégie d'ensemble contre la
haine en ligne et le cyber islamisme et
le principe d'une action de contre
discours républicain c'est ainsi dans
cette stratégie et valider par cet
instant à l'automne 2020
cette démarche s'inspire pour partie de
ce que les Britanniques ont mis en place
depuis 2007 en créant le
riz Cu le retirch une formation et une
communication unit par donner mon accent
une unité constituée au sein du
homophisme pour porter des actions de
contreditours avec à la fois un contre
discours institutionnel porté par une
structure d'État et un contre discours
sociétal porté par des acteurs
associatifs
et la démarche que nous mettons en place
à l'automne 2020 s'inspire pour partie
de cet exemple britannique et selon ce
schéma à deux axes un contre discours
institutionnel qui sera
très rapidement organisé au ministère
intérieur au sein du cpdr avec la
création de l'unité de contrediscours
républicain qui est armé dès novembre
2020 avec de première mise à disposition
puis au père sa montée en puissance sur
le début de 2021 l'unité contrat une
quinzaine d'agents en avril 2021 je ne
prends Marianne est lancé et une
vingtaine d'agents à la fin 2021
on est dès après les attentats qui
frappe la France donc le conseil de
défense dit il faut mettre en place un
fond alors une action de contreditours
républicains
de démarches une démarche
institutionnelle la structure d'État
quantité au sein du cipdr et une
démarche sociétale d'implication des
acteurs associatifs
cette démarche de contourner sur ce
sociétal elle est donc initiée de
l'automne 2020 elle prend appui par
ailleurs sur des expériences sur des
acquis qui sont plus anciens puisque des
2014 2015 il y a au cipdr et au-delà la
volonté d'accompagner la société civile
dans la réaction à l'islamisme c'est pas
que l'initiative stop djihadisme porté
par le
Service d'information du gouvernement
que diriger le préfet Christian Gravel à
l'époque ce sont aussi des actions qui
sont inscrites dans le plan national de
prévention de la radicalisation de 2018
il y a donc depuis déjà plusieurs années
la volonté de promouvoir un contour
discours sociétal mais là il s'agit de
changer l'échelle
et d'agir
vite et fort
pour cela
pour agir en matière de conscience
professional il faut concrètement un
budget
et des partenaires associatifs
le budget c'est assez naturellement le
fond interministériel pour
l'appréhension de la dernière vacances
le FIPD qui a vocation en constitué le
support
nous sommes fin 2020
la loi de finances pour 2021 à reconduit
le SIPD à son niveau de 2020 à 69
millions d'euros
une fois prise en compte la réserve de
précaution il reste 66 millions d'euros
au sein du FPD et le constat qui est
formé très vite par la ministre par
moi-même c'est que le JPD n'est pas en
capacité de financer des actions
nouvelles de contrefu républicain
au niveau où on l'ambitionne sur ces 66
millions d'euros il y a des dépenses qui
sont incompressives en tout cas nous les
apprécions ainsi ce sont les 54 millions
d'euros de crédit qui sont déconcentrés
au préfet pour financer des actions de
proximité dans les territoires de
prévention de la délinquance prévention
de la radicalisation dépend de la
vidéoprotection nous estimons ces
dépenses incompressibles
il y a également le programme dit k
de sécurisation des sites sensibles et
des lieux de culte 4 millions d'euros
que nous estimons également un
compressible et d'ailleurs en gestion
2021 nous allons majorer ce programme de
1 million d'euros supplémentaire il
reste donc 8 millions d'euros au niveau
au sein du FIPD 8 millions d'euros qui
sont gérés au niveau national et qui
sont également en forte tension puisque
nous devons et par redéploiement
financer sur cette enveloppe deux appels
à projet que la ministre en tant que
conduire deux appels à projets sur des
matières qui sont nouvelles pour le FIP
des la lutte contre les dérives sectaire
pour un million d'euros et la lutte
contre les atteintes à la dignité
humaine
c'est à dire la polygamie les mariages
forcés les syndicats de virginité en
référence à des dispositions inscrites
dans le projet de loi confortant le
respect des principes de la République
donc un four à Tamir qui est très
contraint et qui n'a pas la ressource
pour financer même par redéploiement les
actions de contreditours numérique il
faut me trouver des moyens nouveaux
supplémentaires c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous militons nous ferions pour
obtenir un report de crédit de 2020 sur
2021 afin de doter le type et d'une
enveloppe
suffisante pour financer le compte
facebook républicain nous obtenons sur
le métrage du Premier ministre ou son
cabinet
une décision de report de 4 millions
d'euros
début 2021
c'est 4800000 euros ils vont être
affectés à deux priorités ministérielles
le contrediscours républicain pour
2.500000 euros et le développement de la
vidéoprotection dans un contexte où les
contrats de sécurité intégrées se
mettent en place il appelle les
engagements
contractuels de la part de l'État sur la
vidéoprotection avec des dépenses pour
l'équipe des plus importantes les
arbitrages rendus par le ministre
délégué sont affectés ces crédits de
report à parité ou presque entre
vidéoprotection et contre des discours
républicains
donc si les crédits du Fonds Marianne
sont bien des crédits ordinaires du FIPD
ils ont procédé d'un abondement du fond
par rapport de crédits et sur arbitrage
du cabinet du premier ministre pour 2900
000 euros et ce montant est acquis début
deuxième condition réunir pour lancer un
contre discours sociétal avoir des
partenaires associatifs
nous entreprenons quand je le dis nous
aussi le cabinet de la ministre délégué
et le cipdr de rencontrer dès l'automne
2020 des acteurs associatifs qui sont
déjà connus ou qui se sont distingués
pour leur action ou leur réflexion en
matière de contrediscours sociétal qu'il
s'agisse de porter la riposte contre les
campagnes d'influence de programme
séparatiste en ligne ou de promouvoir
toujours sur Internet la valeur de la
République et nous allons
le plus souvent ensemble d'ailleurs
cabinet d'administration c'est des
consignes que je passe à mes
collaborateurs d'administration vous
voyez ensemble des porteurs de projets
potentiellement intéressant et
intéressés pour mesurer leur capacités à
entrer sur des actions de contreditours
républicain et c'est rencontres ces
auditions ces réunions ont avoir lieu de
l'automne 2020 jusqu'à jusqu'au
printemps 2021
je réponds à pas l'occasion de voir deux
acteurs associatifs à mon niveau avant
le lancement du fond Marianne et mes
collaborateurs environ un nombre
important j'en ai pas la liste précise
mais il y a plusieurs associations
connues ou identifiées qui sont reçus
ces deux associations que vous voyez
c'est lesquels vous pouvez les citer
vous m'avez indiqué que vous souhaitez
citer des associations qui étaient déjà
connues peut-être pas d'autres alors ce
sont de là qui n'ont pas été jusqu'à
présent les travaux de la commission
mentionnée je ne souhaite pas pour des
raisons de protection de ces acteurs
associatifs sur un champ qui est un
champ exposant l'émotion de manière
publique je peux faire bien sûr à huis
clos vous communiquez après l'audition
la qualité de ces deux associations que
j'ai rencontré à mon niveau donc entre
fin 2020 début 2021 par des
collaborateurs
vous avez dit tout à l'heure automne
2020 printemps 2021 moi je voudrais des
si vous pouviez avoir des dates plus
précises parce que ça nous amène de
septembre à juin c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose que de novembre à mars
puisque en 2021 le font Marianne vous
voyez ce que je veux dire alors les
rencontres audition avec les acteurs
associatifs ou les intellectuels
impliqués
en matière de contre discours débute en
novembre
et s'achève début avril lorsque décision
est prise de lancer l'appel à projet
il y a donc un certain nombre
d'associations qui vont des avants
lancement de l'appel à projet et même
avant qu'on le décide de lancer l'appel
à projet déposé auprès du cipdr à notre
invitation des demandes de subvention de
manière classique on est sur la gestion
du FIPD dont le régime juridique de la
subvention avec des décisions qui sont
discrétionnaires qui n'en sont pas moins
des décisions réfléchies motivées après
instruction administrative donc qui sont
des décisions discrétionnaires et il y a
donc des février 2021 ma connaissance de
probablement de subventions qui sont qui
sont déposés on reviendra Monsieur le
Préfet on reviendra Monsieur le Préfet
vous le comprenez vous avez utilisé le
terme de motivation bon
motivation
en tout cas qui n'apparaît dans aucun
document voilà donc peut-être qu'il y a
des motivations internes c'est ce que
vous indiquez mais il n'y a aucune
motivation
dans les documents que l'on nous a
transmis mais on y reviendra donc en
tout cas on retient l'idée toute simple
finalement mais sur laquelle on était
arrivé que il y a un travail sur le FIP
des traditionnel voilà PDR d'ailleurs
traditionnel avec une enveloppe Bron il
y a des projections déposées
traditionnellement il y a des
sollicitations qui sont faites vers des
associations connues du cipdr et qui
très logiquement
réfléchissent à un projet avec une
orientation vous me dites si je me
trompe avec une orientation plus comment
dire sur
le commentole le travail en ligne
comment on répond informatiquement
voilà comment comment on utilise les un
peu mieux les réseaux voilà et on en est
là quand on arrive vers la réflexion de
la création du fond Marianne donc je
reviens toujours vers cette question à
quel moment à quel moment et qui décide
de d'appeler finalement
de faire en sorte qui est une
appellation différentielle qu'on ne dise
pas tout simplement c'est le fipdr on
aurait pu avoir une communication très
simple en disant nous renforçons comment
dire les moyens du fipdr nous mettons en
place des moyens supplémentaires qui
permettront de faire ceci cela pourquoi
passe-t-on par finalement une
appellation que Monsieur Gravel
d'ailleurs dénommé comme un label de
communication je reprends exactement ces
termes que j'ai sous les yeux donc à
quel moment et qui décide de finalement
créer quelque chose qui aurait pu être
tout simple et en faire quelque chose
d'un peu plus complexe
et pourquoi
alors la décision de procéder par appel
à projet avec la création du fond du
Marianne elle est prise début avril
début avril je rattache cette décision à
une réunion que j'ai avec le ministre
début avril je crois que c'était le 7
avril à l'issue de laquelle nous
décidons conjointement nous en informons
à l'issue le cabinet plus
d'administration de procéder par appel à
projet et cette décision elle est prise
à mon sens pour deux raisons
la première c'est que nous faisons le
constat début avril après avoir pendant
4 à 5 mois
rencontrés reçus auditionne des
électorat associatifs que nous avons
nous sommes toutes peu de projets
associatifs
potentiellement
déposé pour porter le contrediscours
sociétal j'y reviendrai
et que l'appel à projet est une manière
pertinente de susciter davantage de
projets et de partenariat le deuxième
motif de cette décision c'est un enjeu
de visibilité la ministre souhaite
donner de la visibilité à cette démarche
de contredours qui
avec le lancement du fond Marianne je ne
saurais pas vous dire d'où vient
l'appellation qui l'a proposé
je n'ai pas souvenir je n'ai pas de
trace numérique dans mes archives des
discussions de l'ont conduit à choisir
ce terme-là en tout cas le 7 avril on
décide de procéder par rappel à projet
et l'appellation fond Marianne vient
rapidement après le fonds à label c'est
vrai
comme ça c'est un label
c'est aussi un préciput je raconte
budgétaire une enveloppe de 2500000
euros qui est
identifié qui est fléchée qui est
réservé au sein du FIPD pour financer le
contour des secours sociétal en ligne en
ligne merci beaucoup là-dessus le
Président on est sur la volonté de
soutenir un contre discours en ligne et
pas en général
ce qui se faisait déjà précédemment sur
des actions de formation des acteurs la
conception de maître pédagogie ou autre
on veut agir en ligne sur les réseaux
sociaux
le 7 avril
elle fait elle est communiquée
à l'ensemble du cabinet
à l'administration et le 13 avril
nous avons c'est un mardi nous avons
chaque mardi rien de coordination entre
l'état-major du cipdr et le cabinet
ministériel des réunions que je préside
chaque mardi
où nous allons les orientations et les
actions et donc le 13 avril je fais part
formellement au cipdr de la volonté
d'agir par rapport à projet et je
demande aussi PDR de préparer un texte
pour cet appel à projet en vue d'un
lancement le 20 avril
avec une communication de la ministre
qui s'opérera ce jour-là le 20 avril
est-ce que vous voulez dire qu'avant le
13 avril le cpdr à blanc ne travaille
pas déjà un appel d'offres il n'a pas
été sollicité il apprend le 13 avril
qu'il va y avoir un appel d'offre
il en est informé officiellement lors de
la réunion de coordination du avril il y
avait
je pense des discussions préalables
depuis plusieurs semaines voire
davantage pour choisir le bon vecteur
la procédure classique d'une procédure
discrétionnelle de gras gré
sur laquelle le
IPD a fonctionné intégralement pendant
plusieurs années
ou l'appel à projet et dans les
discussions qu'on peut avoir des
discussions qui sont des discussions
enfin informées des discussions entre le
secrétaire général moi-même les membres
du cabinet les alliances en général
j'ai pas de souvenir très précis et j'ai
pas de traces écrites dans mes archives
et nous avons nécessairement abordé ces
questions le choix du vecteur entre deux
possibilités et nous étions jusqu'en
avril
sur la permodalité qui est la plus
classique la plus courante qui est le
gras gré de manière discrétionnaire et
si nous changeons d'orientation c'est
pour la deux raisons que je vous ai
mentionnées avoir davantage de
partenaires associatifs et donner de la
visibilité à la démarche très bien on
entend ça quelle différence vous faites
entre le gré agréé et l'appel à projet
tel qu'il a été fait finalement puisque
cet appel à projet n'a donné lieu encore
une fois aucune grille de notation
je veux dire quand on regarde les choses
on est très proche du créateur en
réalité résultat
est-ce que quelle est la différence que
vous voyez entre la pratique de cet
appel à projet et le gré à gris
alors moi je vois plusieurs plusieurs
différences
la première et la principale me
semble-t-il c'est que l'appel à projet
comporte par construction une dimension
d'ouverture
et d'appel à candidature
avec un texte d'appel à projet qui
précise les attendus
qui précise le cadre
l'objet avec vous aime ce président deux
grandes actions qui sont éligibles dans
le cadre de l'appel à projet la riposte
a
la propagande séparatiste en ligne ou la
promotion vers de la République des
critères qui sont précisés un dossier à
déposer qui est normé il y a des
éléments qui sont inscrits dans le test
de l'appel à projet sur les pièces
attendues pour pouvoir candidater donc
une démarche je dirais à la fois
d'ouverture et de transparence sur le
cadre le critère et calendrier un
premier caractéristique distinctive de
l'appel à projet par rapport par rapport
au gré à gré
la seconde
je pense c'est que sa place
de fait les candidats dans une démarche
d'équité plus importante que dans le
gras puisque tout un chacun peut
candidater
et que les critères d'appréciation sont
connus ou préciser avant avancelection
on retient on retient votre définition
on reverra point par point si c'est
rempli dans l'opération en question
ce rapporteur
j'ai besoin de précision parce que j'ai
parfois du mal à suivre mais ça me
paraît pas illogique ce que je comprends
qu'il y a quand même
une
[Musique]
confusion entre parfois l'administration
et le cabinet vous avez évoqué donc une
décision communiquée en interne
avez-vous dit le 13 avril
dans ce que vous appelez une réunion de
coordination jusqu'à maintenant
la journée du 13 peut-être vu plusieurs
réunions se succédaient puisque jusqu'à
maintenant on a entendu parler d'un
comité de programmation or au regard de
la question que vient de vous poser le
président était les réunions de
coordination habituelle du mardi
et y a-t-il eu une autre réunion dite
comité de coordination antérieure ou
état à ce moment-là évoqué le fond
Marianne à la réunion du vin voilà
est-ce que vous pouvez
éclairer ma notre lanterne
donc
le 13 avril c'est à la fois
le jour où se tient la réunion
hebdomadaire de coordination et c'est le
jour où nous mettons en place pour la
première fois je crois le comité de
programmation sur les crédits du FIP et
comité
dont la création
a été souhaitée et organisé pour
structurer des échanges jusque là
informels entre le cipdr et le cabinet
ministre sur les sujets budgétaires
c'est donc une seule et même réunion où
il y a deux réunions différentes c'est
un seul temps qui se décompose par une
survenue qui se décompose en deux temps
un temps de programmation
budgétaire et un temple général et
ordinaire sur les autres sujets qui sont
nombreux que nous traitons avec le cipda
donc programmation nous le mettons en
place ce jour là il sera amené à se
réunir autant que de besoin par la suite
sur les questions les questions
financières les questions budgétaires
c'est une démarche que j'ai souhaité
mettre en place et structurer pour
donner de la collégialité et de la
traçabilité dans le processus
décisionnel quant à l'emploi des crédits
budgétaires nous sommes dans un cadre
qui est un cadre qui se veut clair dans
la répartition des rôles
nous allons nous allons y revenir
Monsieur le Préfet
il nous a été indiqué à l'audition
qu'avec l'arrivée de la ministre délégué
madame Marlène Schiappa le 6 juillet
2020 le processus de décision du moins
pour l'attribution des subventions FIPD
était remontée du secrétariat général de
ces PDR au cabinet cela nous a été
indiqué de manière comment dire un petit
peu imprécise d'abord par le secrétaire
général et de manière beaucoup plus
précise par le secrétaire général
adjoint qui indique que donc dès
l'arrivée de la ministre je fais simple
et il y a un changement qu'il voit entre
Octobre et fin d'année où la décision ne
relève plus d'affectation qui était
traditionnellement une responsabilité du
secrétaire général devient une
responsabilité du cabinet est-ce que
vous confirmez
alors je ne sais pas comment les
décisions ont été
préparées et acter avant ma prise de
fonction nous ne prononcerait pas sur ce
point-là ce que je peux confirmer c'est
que il a bien une volonté de la ministre
et du cabinet de pouvoir
décider valider l'emploi des crédits du
FIP aller tu ne les ministres sont
responsables des politiques publiques
sont amenés en rencontres devant leur
banque nationale
autant que de que de besoin que
nécessaire il est légitime normal et
attendu que les ministres et la ministre
délégué décident de l'emploi des crédits
qu'elle a en responsabilité je me
permettrai pas monsieur le Président je
me permettrais pas Monsieur le Préfet de
parler de légitimité ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que l'antériorité n'est pas celle
là c'est à dire que l'antériorité c'est
en gros comme il est souvent le cas le
ministre donne une orientation le
cabinet fait en sorte que
l'administration suive l'orientation de
la ministre c'est bien le moins mais
lorsqu'il y a des procédures procédure
réglementaires lorsqu'il y a des appels
à projets ils sont en fait dans ce cas
comme très souvent dans l'administration
menée par l'administration et dans ce
cas précis par le secrétaire général du
CI PDF donc il y a bien mais vous nous
le confirmez
je mets en débat la question est-ce que
c'est légitime ce qui est légitime c'est
que la ministre voit sa politique
réalisée ça nous sommes d'accord mais
ensuite sur le travail de la ministre le
rôle de la ministre le rôle du cabinet
le rôle de l'administration là par
contre c'est un peu divergent et
d'ailleurs c'est une nouveauté qui est
d'ailleurs remarquée par tous les
salariés du cbda tous les agents qui
voilà un changement de modèle si je puis
dire dans la façon de décider tout
remonte au cabinet alors je voudrais
que vous ayez sur ce point oui mais je
présente je voudrais peut-être préciser
les choses il faut aussi tenir compte du
fait que la ministre est en charge d'un
nouveau ministère délégué à la
citoyenneté qui recouvre pour la
première fois les missions du cpdr Oui
bien au-delà mais c'est la première fois
qu'un nombre de gouvernement est chargé
d'incarner de portée la politique
publique de prévention de la délinquance
et de la radicalisation dans
l'architecture des gouvernements la
première fois et donc la ministre a à
coeur de pouvoir fixer ses orientations
de pouvoir
repriser les choix budgétaires et nous
demandent de l'organiser en conséquence
nous le faisons de manière claire c'est
à dire que le rôle du cabinet auprès de
la ministre c'est un rôle d'orientation
vous l'avez monsieur le Président
d'orientation est de validation
mais pour ce qui est des subventions
nationales
le recueil des demandes
l'instruction des demandes
la proposition de financement relève
d'une phase administrative elle relève
du cipdr
de même que la phase amont de mise en
forme des conventions attributives de
subventions et de suivi relève également
de l'administration le cabinet dans ces
comités de programmation et dans un rôle
d'impulsion de validation pas dans un
rôle
d'instructions dans un rôle d'exécution
on est tout à fait d'accord mais si le
préfet mais
vous dites le mot je veux bien prendre
votre mot c'est pas on va dire
indiqué cette décision vous dites de
validation
je voudrais dire que dans ce cas précis
c'est un synonyme c'est-à-dire que
l'administration propose le cabinet
dispose je fais simple et nous
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure avec le
rapporteur nous verrons quelques cas sur
lequel le cabinet est intervenu soit à
la hausse ou à la baisse et c'est une
intervention cabinet de manière très
claire mais nous vous le poserons mais
je voudrais à ce moment-là de notre
propos puisque depuis hier nous avons le
rapport d'instruction que notre collègue
caoutchi a indiqué tout à l'heure
relatif donc à la subvention versée à
l'uspm dans le cadre il faut Marianne ce
rapport d'inspection du coup comment
dire
pose une question très forte et je
dirais même qu'il le met
en point numéro 1 de ces conclusions
l'enquête de l'inspection de
l'administration de l'igéa aboutit à un
ensemble de conclusions en se limitant à
trois recommandations je vais vous lire
la première
la première l'appel à projet n'a été ni
transparent ni équitable
alors je mets ça en lien avec le rôle du
cabinet justement sur cet appel à projet
on vient d'indiquer et vous l'avez
confirmé
que le cabinet était en responsabilité
de joie de validation vous avez indiqué
à partir de propositions du cpdr aucun
doute mais c'est vous qui avez validé
l'inspection générale d'administration
vous dit que vous avez validé un appel à
projet qui n'a été ni transparent ni
équitable
les mots ont un sens
comment vous réagissez à cet élément
alors moi je n'ai pas d'observation
personnelle à porter sur le rapport de
l'igéa quand on est préfet un rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration
on le lit on intègre sa recommandation
on les met en oeuvre on les commande pas
moi ce que je voudrais dire et par
rapport à votre promotion c'est qu'on a
deux démarches le calendrier est
important on a deux démarches qui se
sont rejointes et chevauchés une
démarche qui court jusqu'au 13 avril où
on est sur la volont le choix de
procéder de manière discrétionnaire et
de gré à gré et à partir de 13 avril une
autre démarche qui serait une démarche
d'appel à projet nous avons le 13 avril
en comme programmation plusieurs
dossiers
qui sont présentés par le sipdr parce
que dansait déjà déposé des demandes de
subvention il y a il y a quatre dossiers
qui sont qui sont déposés et qui
proposent les actions de contreditours
numérique le 13 avril en conte de
programmation le choix qui est fait
c'est de faire de reporter ces dossiers
sur l'appel à projet
et il n'y a pas de dossier
retenu dans le cadre de l'appel à projet
qui était décidé avant
l'appel à projet et transparent il y a
un texte appel à projet il est équitable
semble-t-il au sens où tous les
candidats et tous les lauréats auront vu
leur
subventions leur demande appréciée plus
tard dans le cadre de l'appel à projet
si vous voulez Monsieur le Préfet vous
vous sentez bien qu'il y a un petit
une petite difficulté vous pouvez pas
dire d'abord vous pouvez pas dire que
l'inspection générale c'est la même
chose que le droit quoi
c'est une structure interne qui est
effectivement fait des propositions etc
et je pense d'ailleurs que sur ce
rapport de l'IGA il y aura une réponse
du cpdr du ministère etc c'est la
logique c'est à dire le rapport il est
fait pour susciter du questionnement et
chez nous il suscite plus que du
questionnement parce qu'il est pas posé
encore une fois il est posé un point
numéro un des recommandations et pas de
manière interrogative ou avec une espèce
de souplesse d'interprétation mais au
contraire avec une espèce avec une
affirmation de la part de lija l'appel à
projet n'a été ni transparent ni
équitable alors on va y revenir tout à
l'heure avec justement
leur apporteur qui va point par point
voir un petit peu
qu'est-ce qui est sur la table alors
avant de lui donner la parole je vais je
vais terminer mais je pense que sur ce
sujet simplement de l'équité de la
transparence les auditions précédentes
que nous avons eu
des squelette en général secrétaire
général adjoint
des associations
si on relève bien tout ce qui a été dit
par les uns par les autres sincèrement
lorsque j'ai lu ce matin hier soir plus
exactement que l'appel à projet n'a été
ni transparent ni équitable doit vous
dire que
peut-être qu'on verra ce qu'on écrira
dans notre propre rapport enfin c'est
pas quelque chose qui nous a tout à fait
tout à fait étonné on le verra on le
verra tout à l'heure alors juste avant
juste avant Monsieur le Préfet on va y
revenir vous inquiétez pas c'est un
sujet qui est important
le cabinet donc on va essayer de rentrer
dans ce dossier puisque c'est le seul
pour l'instant qui est d'ailleurs
regardé par l'Inspection Générale
d'administration on nous promet pour la
fin du mois un rapport un peu plus un
peu plus large mais on a si je puis dire
les presque les bonnes feuilles si je
puis dire du rapport final ou complet
sur sur un dossier qui est particulier
qui concerne donc une association l'use
ppm et bien sûr apparaît dans ce dans ce
dossier Monsieur Mohamed cifaoui qui
s'est d'ailleurs beaucoup exprimé dans
la presse contrairement à vous je dois
le dire et à nous qui ne l'avons pas
fait non plus sinon sous la forme de
conférence de presse et donc
je vais vous poser deux questions puis
je vais ouvrir le débat à mes collègues
d'abord sur le monsieur Mohamed syfaoui
j'ai exprimait dans la presse
en disant que en gros on est allé le
chercher excusez-moi cette formule un
peu un peu lapidaire mais en tout cas
que le cabinet et la ministre et où
d'ailleurs le ski se présentera il
viendra nous préciser des choses
la contacter en sachant que Monsieur
Sifaoui avait déjà travaillé pour le
cpdr sur des questions de formation
semble-t-il donc est-ce que le cabinet a
eu oui ou non est-ce que vous pouvez
nous confirmer des contacts avec
Monsieur mohammati antérieurement à
l'élaboration du fond Marianne et si oui
pouvez-vous nous préciser la teneur de
ces contacts
un acteur qui est connu qui fait
en quelque sorte références en matériaux
contre l'islamisme et le cigariste qui
faisait déjà du contre le discours
sociétal à travers ces réseaux sociaux
ou le site islamoscope qu'il avait créé
à titre personnel
et à ce titre il a été reçu par le Cami
de la ministre et le cipdr par vous même
donc par le cabinet de la ministre par
vous-même ah non non pas
mes collaborateurs au cabinet merci
notamment le Conseil spécial de la
ministre qui était en charge de
piloter les actions de contrediscours
avec d'autres membres du cabinet et le
cipdr à une ou plusieurs reprises je ne
serai pas le directe précision en tout
cas il a été reçu bien évidemment au
cabinet à sa demande
je saurais pas vous le dire je pense
qu'on l'a je pense qu'on l'a
solliciterait certainement très
certainement pour avoir un échange avec
lui sur sa vision des choses c'est sa
réflexion la façon dont il appréhende
l'enjeu du Grand publicain qui est une
action publique nouvelle on est en train
d'expérimenter d'innover on a besoin
d'élémentiers de réflexion collective de
rencontrer des acteurs des chercheurs
des scientifiques donc c'est une phase
de consultation assez intense
et la personne que vous avez cité va
début avril
présenté un projet alors là nous la nous
y revenons parce que nous aurons
effectivement la question sur la teneur
des différents rencontres qu'il y a pu
avoir monsieur Sifaoui dans un premier
temps donc on propose d'y revenir un peu
un peu plus loin
donc
Christian Gravel dit j'ai appris que
l'USPPM pourrait bénéficier des fonds
Marianne lors d'un appel téléphonique de
Monsieur cifaoui donc ça vient pas par
le cabinet qu'on aurait pu imaginer mais
ça vient par Monsieur cifaoui qui sort
d'un rendez-vous nous dit-il avec la
ministre ou le cabinet on reste prudent
sur cela mais
que donc son implication son
investissement lui permettre de
prétendre à effectivement pouvoir
répondre donc quand est-ce que ce
rendez-vous a eu lieu
[Musique]
ce premier rendez-vous
je dépose tout serment oui
la ministre n'a pas reçu Monsieur
Sifaoui très bien ma connaissance
pour le compte de la ministre le 22
avril
à 15h15
au Canada ministre un rendez-vous qui
était organisé par par le secrétaire
particulier de ministre pour qu'elle
reçoive la personne que vous avez cité
également la ministre n'a pas pu pour
des raisons de confie d'agenda et
d'urgence assurés sur rendez-vous même
et de la représenter donc j'ai reçu et
c'est le seul rendez-vous que j'aurais
avec motif à Wii sur ces questions là le
22 avril à 15h15
et je suis très clair et très précis sur
ce point mes collaborateurs au cabinet
de cipdr ont pu rencontrer Monsieur
Sifaoui à plusieurs reprises
précédemment très certainement
fin mars fin mars début avril également
il y a pu y avoir une il y a eu une
incitation une invitation à
envisager un projet associatif pour
recevoir un soutien
du cipdr et une fois que ce projet a eu
été communiqué et déposé je crois que
c'est le 9 avril c'est le cpdr dans ces
missions
administratives de gestion de
subventions qui a géré l'entièreté de la
relation avec les porteurs de projet en
ce qui concerne en vrai on va y revenir
simplement
vous le savez le rapport de l'inspection
indique qu'il y a eu ces rencontres
entre mars et avril 2021 entre votre
cabinet de manière large il y en a une
avec vous mais c'est ainsi que c'est
indiqué dans le rapport de l'inspection
le réforme se présente me semble-t-il
retranscrit les propos tenus par l'un
des protagonistes
et l'inspection dans une autre bas de
page précise qu'elle n'est pas en mesure
de déterminer le nombre de natures des
rayons qui se sont tenus on en tiendra
compte on va faire une petite pause
avant de donner la parole rapporteur
avec quelques questions de dessinateur
dans la salle monsieur karucci
monsieur le Président d'abord
permettez-moi de dire je m'élève un
petit peu en agacement sur la
dialectique qui n'est pas celle de
Monsieur le Préfet mais ça m'agace un
peu d'entendre dire le contre discours
républicain mais dans cette venue un
formules à la mode comme si ceux d'en
face avait un discours républicain que
nous on avait un contre discours
républicain il y a un seul discours
républicain et il y a ceux qui ne l'ont
pas donc arrêtons de dire contre
discours c'est l'impression d'être dans
un débat avec d'autres qui ont une autre
acceptation de la République qui n'a
qu'une seule acceptation de la
République
deuxième élément Monsieur le Préfet moi
depuis le début de cette affaire je me
dis mais
expérience absolue les associations qui
ont été d'une manière ou d'une autre
associée au fond Marianne apporte de
plus que ne pouvait apporter les
structures publiques
il existe on en a vu des campagnes
organisées par le service d'intérêt d'un
service d'information du gouvernement
qui a quand même un budget d'une
quinzaine de millions d'euros qui
emploie 90 personnes il y a le cipdr qui
existe depuis 2006 qui emploie lui-même
une soixantaine de personnes
dans le fond est-ce que les associations
apportées une telle différence de
capacité de messages ou d'expérience
qu'on ne puisse pas passer que par les
structures publiques on a vu pendant un
certain nombre de problèmes la pandémie
ou autre des campagnes aussi bien
d'ailleurs dans les médias publics que
sur les réseaux sociaux qui étaient
plutôt bien faites et qui était fait
directement soit par les ministères soit
par les structures publiques est-ce que
réellement quand on voit les clips qu'on
a vu des associations est-ce que
réellement
les structures publiques étaient
incapables de faire ce genre de d'action
est-ce que réellement on considère que
les associations ont eu un plus très
différent très bénéfique par rapport à
ce qu'on aurait pu faire les structures
publiques
sur le préfet si en quelques mots vous
pouvez répondre à notre collègue
moi je vous rejoins je le disais il y a
deux modalités pour le contredours alors
républicain c'est le discours de la
République comporte contre les émis de
la République c'est vrai que les termes
peuvent être
policémiques ou ambiguë il y a deux
modalités le contreditours
institutionnel au grand discours
sociétal
nous mettons la priorité sur le compte
de discours institutionnel avec la
création dès novembre 2020 de l'unité de
contreditours au sein du cipdr
et je le précise un effort significatif
qui est porté puisque le Premier
ministre au Parlement automne 2020
annonce le renforcement des services du
ministère de l'Intérieur contre la ligne
cyber islamisme à hauteur de 100 et TP
100 emplois et cette décision est
naturellement suivie des faits et c'est
ce qui permettra de renforcer les
effectifs de la plateforme Pharos de
renforcer les services de renseignement
de renforcer certaines préfectures
également et d'armée l'unité de
contredits républicain à hauteur de 35
ETP au sein du cpdr avec donc 20 UTP qui
sont mobilisés en 2021 et le seul qui
doit l'être par la suite donc la
priorité est bien mise y compris en
termes de choix budgétaire sur le contre
discours institutionnel
lequel peut rencontrer aussi des limites
puisque c'est un contre discours qui
intervient sur compte public le compte
du cipdr le compte République
tirait tirez-vous donc un message public
qui se veut fort mais qui est un message
public et qui peut auprès de certains et
je pense auprès des jeunes parfois en
particulier être un discours qui a moins
de portée que s'il est
exprimé par des acteurs de la société
civile et nous éprouvons le besoin de
mobiliser la société civile d'avoir des
acteurs associatifs qui portent cette
parole sur le vol de la République
sur la lutte contre les idées
séparatistes extrémistes complotistes
d'autres pays l'ont fait citer l'exemple
du Royaume-Uni
notre pays le mettait en place depuis
plusieurs années depuis 2014-2015 et là
nous décidons de le faire je dirais
en grand ou de manière plus volontariste
avec un budget dédié et des partenaires
qu'on souhaite être plus nombreux
si je dirais nécessaire
à la fois pour mobiliser la société
civile et pour avoir une une parole qui
soit aussi mieux entendu par ce auquel
elle s'adresse aux paroles qui portent
pas le label ministère de l'Intérieur
quoi pour le dire très clairement
si vous motorisez
chers collègues Breuillet puis ensuite
nous reviendrons vers le rapporteur
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur Monsieur le Préfet
j'ai deux questions est-ce imaginables
que Monsieur cifaoui
contacte cipdr en lui disant je sors du
cabinet de la ministre j'ai je vais être
subventionné pour participer à ce
discours
est-ce que c'est une initiative
imaginable par un de vos collaborateurs
que que de dire à une personne
a contacté le cpdr on va vous soutenir
je ne comprends pas vous avez parlé de
la collégialité de la décision vous avez
évoqué que vous n'avez vu vous-même
monsieur cifaoui que le 22 avril mais
monsieur Gravel nous dit que monsieur
cifaoui est venu le voir en lui
indiquant que il allaite subventionné
oui donc enfin c'est ma première
question et la deuxième c'est sur le
contrediscours parce que moi je trouve
intéressant cette idée d'un contre
discours on voit bien que dans la
jeunesse le discours officiel parfois
passe mal mais je ne comprends pas j'ai
le sentiment que il est construit au
hasard de rencontre est-ce qu'il y a pas
du côté du ministère une analyse des
ressources disponibles des il y a des
chercheurs qui travaillent aussi en
sciences humaines surtout enfin est-ce
qu'il y a une analyse préalable avant de
contacter telle ou tel et lui proposait
finalement de rentrer dans ce bateau du
contre discours républicain dans ce
navire de la lutte contre l'islamisme
radical
de réponse courte Monsieur le Préfet oui
il y a une mettons en place une action
pluie qui est nouvelle
qui n'a qui a peu de précédents et donc
on le fait en consultant des chercheurs
des intellectuels des journalistes des
scientifiques un certain nombre de pas
la liste avec quoi mais je pourrais vous
les préciser au-delà de la au-delà de
l'audition pour réfléchir à la façon
dont les choses peuvent se mettre en
place au mieux
et nous recevons aussi des acteurs
associatifs
certains sont invités à formaliser un
projet il y a se rapprocher du CPL pour
aller sur une demande de subvention et
c'est ce qui se passe avec monsieur
cifaoui qui a reçu alors à une ou
plusieurs reprises sur une discussion
générale et qui vient au cabinet début
avril il est reçu par le cabinet et par
le cadrage du cipdr pour présenter le
projet illik oui
en termes verbaux et généraux
et Monsieur chiffoli sera invité par un
collaborateur du cabinet par mail à se
rapprocher du cipdr pour voir comment
déposer un dossier et à partir de là on
passe dans une phase qui est une phase
administrative
strictement
d'examens de sa demande d'instruction
puis de proposition
il n'est pris vis-à-vis de
la personne aucun engagement d'aucune
sorte
et même quand je le reçois le 22 avril
pour le compte de la ministre je ne
prends pas d'engagement financier dans
une phase administrative on attend
d'avoir un dossier d'avoir l'instruction
de ce dossier par l'administration
d'avoir une proposition de financement
par l'administration pour se prononcer
et ça on le fera je pense qu'on en parle
dans quelques instants en comité dit de
sélection le le
le 21 ou le 22 mai qui suit
sur la deuxième question
qui concernait les compétences
pas de remarques particulières
on a consulté non mais on a consulté on
a consulté on a consulté très largement
y compris dans la phase de préparation
du projet de loi confortant les
principes de la République on a consulté
beaucoup d'acteurs scientifiques
culturels
administrative politique on a consulté
abondamment sur l'ensemble de mes sujets
dans la phase de préparation du projet
de loi
puis dans la réflexion autour de la mise
en place du contrôle républicain les
concessions étaient intenses et très
nombreuses et nous n'avons pas eu
n'avons pas eu
de
proposition
on comprend bien Monsieur le Préfet là
vous le dites depuis ce matin ça nous a
été dit par d'autres la difficulté à
laquelle l'État est confronté
des annonces
ambitieuses et une difficulté le
discours institutionnel manifestement ne
passe pas et ou pas comme l'étal
souhaiterait et aller chercher des
partenaires notamment du monde
associatif mais je vous redis moi je
trouve qu'il y a une zone là il y a du
flou il y a du mélange bon alors je vais
essayer de rentrer de manière assez
méthodique dans le déroulement de la
procédure donc
vous l'avez dit il y a quelques instants
et ses repris dans le rapport de Liga il
y a il y aurait donc eu deux réunions
lors desquelles monsieur Sifaoui dit
avoir
eu un échange au mois de salutations
avec la ministre
pouvez-vous donc nous nous confirmer
parce que ça a pas l'air d'être tout à
fait le cas et nous dire sur quoi dans
ces deux cas précis les échanges
emportés est-ce que déjà il était
question de la subvention oui ou non et
d'un montant oui ou non
alors
sur ces questions très précises monsieur
le rapporteur donc il y a eu un ou
plusieurs rendez-vous avec le cabinet de
la ministre pas au niveau du cabinet au
niveau du cabinet fin avril fin mars
début avril
pour évoquer
l'enjeu du contre du four de manière
générale et les monter une réflexion
collective et aussi dans un deuxième
temps
pour que monsieur siphonie présente le
projet hilaïque au cabinet au cpdr on
est donc début avril
cette proposition fait Louise une
demande de subvention que je situe au 9
avril un dossier déposé au cipdr le 9
avril le projet hilaïque porté par
l'association
uspm
nous sommes amenés le 13 avril
en comité de programmation à examiner
plusieurs dossiers de demande de
subvention
instruit par par le cipda
il y a malheureusement peu vous l'avez
dit de trace de cette de ce comité
de ce qui s'est dit excusez-moi de vous
dire enfin je redis ici ma surprise de
voir sur un sujet comme celui-ci avec
les procédures vous l'avez dit notamment
menée par l'administration
l'absence de
compte-rendu de traces de dépôt enfin ça
va quand même là aussi dans la question
de la transparence sur un sujet comme
celui-ci en plus et vu porter sous les
feux de l'actualité en tous les cas dans
les annonces c'est ça m'étonne
je comprends et je le partage nous
sommes dans une phase de mise en place
de structuration de ce processus
décisionnel et les choses vont
s'améliorer et se mettre en place
progressivement et à l'été qui suit à
l'état 2020 sur notre Apple à projets
ne se passeront pas comme ça seront
beaucoup plus formalisés et normalisés
et puis je vais cocher d'avancer parce
que
je peux pas comprendre ce que je
comprends pas votre réponse je sens
l'embarras la gêne mais vous pouvez pas
répondre à une question qui porte c'est
une réunion de mars 2021 en me disant
mais en 2020 ça s'est pas passé comme ça
si on tire les anciennes si on tire pas
ou si on fait l'inverse de ce qu'il
faudrait faire voilà donc je voudrais
juste reposer la question sur les
déclarations de Monsieur Sifaoui qui a
eu qui aurait eu plusieurs réunions donc
avec
vos services et dans deux d'entre elles
il aurait
salué la ministre et donc est-ce que
vous confirmez et deuxièmement quel a
été le contenu de l'échange à ce
moment-là avec Monsieur cifaoui
de dérouler le fil
[Musique]
pour le coup c'est moi qui pose la
question vous essayez d'y répondre je
vais après vous parler d'une réunion du
24 mars puis du 6 avril j'essaie de
prendre la chronologie puisque il vous a
pas échappé que ça fait un certain temps
qu'on travaille et on a besoin d'être
précis sur la chronologie qui est à dire
de à convenir ensemble un moment ça y
est on a ça on l'a traité de telle
manière voilà si vous voulez bien alors
je confirme ma réponse se présente sur
rapporteur la ministre n'a pas rencontré
ni reçu le monsieur cifaoui le 22 avril
à 15h15 je reçois pour le compte de la
ministre monsieur cifaoui la ministre
est passé le salut cursivement elle ne
sait pas attardée c'est pas assise elle
l'a salué cursivement
je vais revenir parce que c'est le 22
avril j'ai quelques
réunions avant donc il y a une réunion
qui se tient le 24 mars
en présence je me suis fait oui du
préfet Gravel est plusieurs membres du
cabinet avez-vous participé à cette
réunion et pouvez-vous nous dire qu'elle
était le contenu le 24 mars
alors il y a eu une ou plusieurs
réunions au niveau des cabinets entre
pharmacie des 2 avril je n'ai pas parce
qu'il concerne les dates précises de ces
réunions avec auxquelles je n'étais pas
auquel je n'étais pas
et il y a eu mon indiqué mes anciens
collaborateurs
au moins une réunion d'échange général
qui peut être celle de la fin du mois de
mars et une deuxième réunion début avril
de discussion sur un projet présenté par
Monsieur Sifaoui donc le D donc vous
n'étiez pas personnellement à celle du
24 mars
il est fort probable qu'elle a eu lieu
c'est ce que vous dites probablement ce
qui est sûr d'ailleurs puisque ça nous a
été dit avec des membres de votre
cabinet
dont il n'est pas il n'y a pas de compte
rendu il y a pas à votre connaissance en
tout cas c'est ce que vous ne déclarez
deuxième temps le 6 avril en présence de
Monsieur Sifaoui toujours du préfet
Gravel de monsieur
urdi qui est un des conseillers en
charge le conseiller
patient avec les élus et les
collectivités donc une réunion objet
contenu des décisions
alors il y a une deuxième réunion très
certainement début avril sur le projet
illaïque présenté par par Monsieur
cifaoui je n'ai pas la composition de
cette réunion ce que je peux vous
indiquer c'est que le concile référent
sur le contrediscount et le fond
Marianne c'est le consier spécial de la
ministre et que les rencontres
écosystifaoui ont dû se faire à son
niveau à son niveau mais donc vous êtes
en train de me dire qu'en tant que chef
de cabinet
vous n'avez pas connaissance
de je dirais de ni du contenu ni parfois
même de la tenue des réunions enfin
c'est bien ce que vous venez de me dire
alors vous me parlez de faits qui sont
produits il y a plus de deux années
monsieur le rapporteur mais je sais bien
trace numérique il m'est difficile de
vous dire avec précision comment les
choses se sont déroulées à ces moments
là je vous ai dit de manière constante
et à trois reprises déjà qu'il y a eu un
ou plusieurs rendez-vous au niveau du
kennel de la ministre
monsieur préfet j'entends mais vous êtes
chef de cabinet directeur de cabinet
vous avez donc la responsabilité
de l'organisation des temps d'échanges
sur un sujet qui est pas un sujet mineur
enfin
j'ai quand même enfin vous savez que
vous allez être auditionné
en général on va rechercher tout le
maximum d'éléments disponibles s'il y a
pas d'éléments disponibles
je continue de dire à ce stade sa
méthode
voilà dans d'autres auditions on a eu
des éléments très précis donc
voilà la question de la transparence
c'est de la parfaite connaissance
pour répondre à votre question
je vous le disais je suis au cabinet le
seul à disponible déviation de signature
de la ministre nous pouvons imaginer une
décision ministérielle il n'y a pas eu
sur ces rendez-vous
accordés à Monsieur Sifaoui de décision
de prise ou d'envisager autrement j'en
aurai été avisé j'aurais été sollicité
préalablement sur des audiences comme il
y en a comme il s'en produit toutes les
semaines au cabinet qui n'ont pas de
mieux les décisions les décisions et
Monsieur Sifaoui donc enfin lieu CPM va
déposer un dossier de demande de
subvention je ne la trace dans un
tableau qui vous a été communiqué je
pense je tiens à votre disposition
autrement monsieur rapporteur un tableau
qui suit le créneau de programmation du
13 avril
on voit que le projet déposé par l'uspm
le 9 est abordé le 13 avril en comité de
programmation qui n'est pas validé qui
n'est pas validé et que le cabinet c'est
à dire votre serviteur
demande à ce que le projet soit affiné
qu'on
associe l'engagement du porteur de
projet à des indicateurs de résultats de
réalisation très très précis et on
renvoie sur l'appel à projets à venir
sur le fond Marianne l'examen de ce
projet qu'il en est de même pour les
autres projets déposés en matière de
contreditours numérique
je poursuis donc plusieurs réunions
entre la ministre cabinet monsieur
cifaoui qui était présent pour l'instant
il y a tout n'est pas concordant est-ce
que a été quand a été abordé
l'existence notamment pour Monsieur
cifaoui de l'uzé ppm
quand avez-vous eu connaissance de
cette association donc moi j'ai
connaissance de s'association lorsqu'on
aborde la demande de subvention le 13
avril en comité de programmation
j'aurais l'occasion lorsque je reçois
monsieur siffle le 22 avril il vient
qu'une autre personne dont je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas le nom dans mon agenda il y
a pas l'occurrence il y a pas le nom de
la personne qui l'accompagne ils sont
deux sur ne pas la personne en question
visuellement il y a ce que c'est présent
qui ont du cabinet et on aborde de
nouveau le portage associatif par
l'ueppm je prends note de ce qui me
présentait et je vais demander alors je
sais plus si c'est avant ou après mais
je vais demander expressément à ce qu'on
regarde
et à ce qu'on vérifie la le sérieux de
l'association en question qui
porte un nom et un objet social a priori
assez large
qui est parisienne ou local
et qui n'a pas été jusqu'à présent
accompagné par par le célibataire donc
je demande à ce que on vérifie que
l'association en question est à la fois
crédible et sérieuse donc vous dites que
vous
en connaissez l'existence seulement vous
en apprenez l'existence le 22 avril
le 13 avril comme sa programmation on
aborde la demande de subventions déposée
par l'ueppm et le il y avait une réunion
avant le 9 avril est-ce que des membres
du cabinet puisque il y avait le
programme habituel vous l'avez dit elle
appelle à projet est-ce que des membres
du cabinet avaient donc puisque c'est
quand même ce qui a été dit par certains
certaines des personnes additionnées
avaient envoyé des messages en disant
préparez-vous à répondre
quelle a été le rôle d'action soit du
cabinet ou la vôtre
alors l'appel à projet il est décidé
de l'organiser après ces rencontres avec
Monsieur silvery ou d'autres on est on
est après on est après donc c'est après
le 22 avril non c'est avant après après
les réunions de début avril après on est
sur des questions mais on est sur des
questions qui sont extrêmement précises
et je l'entends qu'il faut une
information judiciaire
financier vos moditionnez dans un cadre
qui est différent avec des questions qui
sont extrêmement précises sur lesquels
je n'ai pas avec moi les éléments de
documentation qui me serait nécessaire
je n'ai pas non plus d'appui d'un avocat
il me paraît délicat d'être dans cet
exercice qui est légitime et auquel je
m'étonne complètement sans avoir des
garanties minimales de défense et de
protection
je j'entends votre ce que je vais
appeler une objection vous n'êtes pas
ici dans une procédure judiciaire vous
êtes vous le savez bien dans le cadre
d'une commission d'enquête et on essaie
simplement enfin moi j'essaie de à la
fois de comprendre et par la matérialité
des faits des rencontres puisqu'on a eu
comme on vous auditionne aujourd'hui on
a quand même reçu un certain nombre de
personnes qui nous ont donné de manière
très précise la chronologie vous
connaissez l'objet moi j'ai besoin de
nous avons besoin de comprendre la
matérialité la réalité des faits la
chronologie comment les choses et puis
vous l'avez bien compris il y a quand
même des enjeux
politiques certes mais là d'abord un
contrôle de l'action publique et des
dépenses qui sont engagées donc parait
pas inconvenant
ni déplacer de s'assurer que les
procédures
auquel l'administration dans toutes ces
exercices de ces responsabilités obéi
quel que soit le cadre enfin donc
je vous sens un peu agacé et sur la
défensive il y a simplement une scène
curiosité et je le dis essayer d'avoir
des faits relativement enfin le plus
précis possible
je vais vous
je réponds aux questions que vous me
posez
pour ce qui concerne action qui a été la
Bienne je vous le dis le 13 avril de
programmation nous met présenté ce
projet du lieu CPPM il n'est pas validé
le 13 avril et je retiens l'échange que
vous ayez la semaine sur la porter avec
le prix de l'Association vous dites au
président décision est prise de 13 avril
et le Président vous répond
je l'ignore il n'y a pas eu de décision
prise de 13 avril et aucun des futurs le
ras du fond Marianne ne sera avisé après
le 13 avril une décision leur faveur
j'insiste beaucoup sur ce point qui est
factuellement établi le 22 avril quand
je reçois monsieur cifaoui pour la
première fois pour ce qui me concerne
pour le compte de la ministre nous
échangeons sur le projet qu'il présente
je n'ai pas de souvenir précis de cet
entraîneur qui n'a pas choisi un compte
rendu mais ce que je peux assurer c'est
qu'il n'a pas eu d'engagement financier
de ma part et de la part de la ministre
sur le projet qu'il porte
et tous les échanges qui ont lieu sur le
projet sont menés par l'administration
par le cipdr de manière constante à
partir du dossier déposé le 9 avril je
vous communiquer de sélection le 22 mai
l'ensemble des échanges entre lieu ce
ppm et le ministère sont conduits par
l'administration qui est dans son rôle
de réception d'un dossier d'instruction
de proposition d'un niveau de
financement le cabinet est dans le sien
dans l'impulsion préalable que dans la
validation mais chacun est dans sa
responsabilité d'accord et c'était donc
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure à l'issue
de cette entretien vous avez demandé au
secrétariat général du cpdr de mener
quelques investigations pour
comprendre quel était la réalité la
matérialité de l'association vous l'avez
dit son objet qui paraissait pas
forcément et naturellement spontanément
parfaitement approprié les les
renseignements que vous avez eu donc je
pense rapidement vous ont rassuré
et finalement conforté pour permettre
ensuite l'octroi de la subvention de
300.000 euros qui a été accordé
alors oui donc le 22 avril après cet
entretien je ne sais plus si c'est avant
ou après l'entretien je demande
expressément à mes collaborateurs à
l'administration de regarder de plus
près ce qu'est l'association en question
pour les raisons que je vous ai
indiquées la réponse peut apporter en
comité de sélection le 22 mai lorsqu'on
aborde les dossiers qui sont qui sont
présentés proposés par l'administration
et ce que j'en ai retenu c'est que la
plantation qui me faite est positive et
qu'on me met en avant le statut
d'association reconnue d'utilité
publique de l'UEFA je n'ai pas moi-même
la capacité vous l'imaginer de procéder
des contrôles sur des sujets comme
celui-ci je fais confiance à mon
administration j'ai passé consigne qu'on
vérifie le point on m'en fait un retour
qui est positif je considère que la
réserve est levée manifestement et au vu
de ce qui se passera par la suite
à regret mais la question que j'ai posée
a trouvé une réponse est apporté qui est
une réponse positive voilà deux à ce
stade deux dernières questions qui
touche plutôt au regard de d'autres
associations
est-ce que vous aviez des contacts avec
reconstruire le coma qui a également
obtenu
300.000 euros de subventions puisque
vous les aviez avant l'appel à projet
est-ce qu'il y a eu des temps d'échanges
de réunions
et si oui qu'elle a été un peu la teneur
de ces échanges alors pour reconstruire
le commun
il n'y a pas eu à ma connaissance
de rencontre d'échanges avec le cabinet
de la ministre
je ne connaissais pas l'association
moi-même mais mes collaborateurs non
plus lorsque nous examinons la
proposition de demande de subvention le
22 mai en comité de sélection
dernière question
c'est un peu la même avec d'autres
associations qui sont finalement
retenues puisque je le redis il y a
aussi un dialogue avec certaines
associations est-ce que vous aviez eu
des échanges préables qui d'ailleurs ont
pu permettre de dire vous aurez votre
financement habituel
sous-entendu le fond Marianne c'est une
autre procédure
avec un arbitrage soit de les conserver
hors fond Marianne soit de les
rendre éligibles pour un projet soit
supplémentaire soit nouveau
au projet Marianne au fond Marianne oui
alors on est vraiment sur les actions
qu'on peut discours numérique et on a
en 2021 très peu d'associations qui sont
sur ce terrain là avec des financements
du FIP des
très peu il y a deux phases qui se
chevauchent la première phase où on est
dans la posture de gragrée on cherche
des patients associatives on rencontre
on sollicite on démarche pour avoir des
projets qui émergent et un certain
nombre d'émerger avant lancement de
l'appel à projet
et l'appel approché lui-même qui
intervient après il y a des projets
déposés avant sur lequel nous ne prenons
pas de décision parce que
ces projets vocations à être versés dans
l'appel à projet et avoir leur demande
apprécié dans le cadre du Fonds
[Musique]
de sélection sur l'appel à projet
d'abord il y a eu donc un appel à projet
qui a été réalisé à votre demande par le
cipdr est-ce que le cabinet modifié cet
appel à projet ou à souhaiter y amener
des indications particulières et si oui
lesquelles oui alors il y a le 13 avril
je demande à l'administration de
proposer un texte pour l'appel à projet
qui nous est communiqué assez rapidement
il y a un échange entre cabinet et
l'administration sur le texte lui-même
des modifications qui sont apportées
notamment sur le calendrier
nous sommes dans une des délais qui sont
courts je reconnais je l'assume bien
volontiers dans un contexte qui est
celui d'une menace terroriste qui se
situe un niveau extrêmement élevé
au mois d'avril 2021 nous avons la
Transat terroriste de Rambouillet
commissaire de Rambouillet le 23 avril
on est sur contexte là et vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président de votre
conférence initial ce sont des éléments
qui sont très importants de
circonstances exceptionnelle qui
explique et justifie me semble-t-il les
démarches et les délais très
volontariste qui ont été retenus
nous prévoyons d'avoir trois semaines du
20 avril au 10 mai pour le dépôt des
dossiers de candidature
avec
le souci de retirer des projets qui
soient opérationnels murs et prédéma je
crois que le texte de la police dans les
45 jours qui suivent l'identification de
la subvention
j'exprime par ailleurs au cipdr la
priorité l'accord de la ministre à cet
appel à projet fond Marianne donc une
demande de mobilisation qui est faite à
notre administration
et si c'est délai son cours c'est vrai
ils n'en sont pas moins tenables et nous
aurons sur ce pas de temps de trois
semaines plus de 70 dossiers qui vont
être déposés ce qui montre que des
acteurs associatifs et tout à fait en
capacité de répondre dans l'urgence sur
l'appel à projet qui était le nôtre
oui tout d'abord vous avez encore
accéléré par rapport à ce qui était le
premier projet le premier projet c'était
finalement un déroulé entre le 1er mai
et le 30 juin et sur votre demande il y
a une accélération c'est à dire c'est
ramener à fin de mai début juin donc
effectivement il y a un système
d'accélération j'entends et on partage
le fait qu'il faut toujours se mettre en
mémoire du temps dans lequel on est il y
a pas de doute là-dessus en même temps
qu'on pourrait d'ailleurs votre
présentation initiale le disait le fond
Marianne n'est qu'un élément particulier
c'est pas la création d'un fond Marianne
et de mise en route le truc qui va être
de nature à contrer un risque un risque
immédiat donc c'est plutôt je crois très
clairement une
comment dire une communication que le
gouvernement veut positive sur le fait
qu'il agit bon voilà
et j'allais dire que c'est quelque chose
qu'on se retrouve assez régulièrement
quand il y a un problème
un incident dans le cas précis un
attentat il y a toujours une volonté de
pouvoir afficher une réponse une réponse
rapide malheureusement on a vu et vous
l'avez dit puisque vous avez dit
malheureusement etc c'est que ça induit
effectivement des manques de
surveillance ça induit dans le choix des
partenaires manquent un peu de vigilance
puisqu'on va vite et on repère pas
effectivement que l'association par
exemple en question dont on parle
sociaux qui a jamais dépassé 50000 euros
de chiffre de budget annuel bon donc
quand elle demande elle-même pour la
première fois 600.000 euros parce qu'on
est on est à cette à ce niveau au départ
la première demande initiale bon on voit
bien qu'on est hors-jeu complet par
rapport à la capacité à faire surtout
dans un système financé par l'État ou le
financement on le sait bien arrive
toujours à quelques mois de retard il
faut porter l'action pendant quelques
temps donc cette accélération du système
n'a pas n'est pas toujours
très très propice vous nous dites que
vous allez être à l'origine mais il y a
sans doute dans ce délai contraint
beaucoup de réseau
finalement de d'arriver à des soucis par
la suite et d'ailleurs si vous aviez
aujourd'hui un peu à froid si je puis
dire les choses de à vous poser la
question de ce délai est-ce que vous
répondriez vraiment que vous venez de le
faire en disant finalement 73 projets
mais en réalité vous avez pas eu 60 ans
de projets vous avez quelques projets
significatifs et des tout petits projets
si vous voulez quelques milliers d'euros
ou dizaines de milliers d'euros on est
sur des choses beaucoup plus modestes et
en fait vous avez quatre associations
qui prennent deux tiers des montants et
c'est bien ces quatre associations sur
lesquelles vous appuyez en priorité de
avec lesquels vous avez une habitude de
travail aussi PDR et de nouvelles qui
sont donc désignés dans l'urgence et cet
aspect là nous paraît important est-ce
que si vous aviez à le refaire
aujourd'hui vous diriez non ben on a eu
des réponses et ça marche quoi
le contexte est important parce que on
est dans cet obligation ardente d'agir
et on le fait dans tous les domaines
la plateforme Pharos c'est le renforcer
en l'espace de deux mois une telle
construire un républicain la mise en
place en l'espace de quelques semaines
le pot national contre la haine en ligne
au sein du parquet de Paris il est créé
en janvier 2021 le projet de loi
confortant le respect de la République
il est présenté sur la posture d'urgence
au Parlement on est dans cette urgence
cette ante obligation qui oblige à aller
vite
avoir plus de temps aurait été
préférable je vous l'accorde je pense
qu'on aurait pas forcément pris trois
mois clairement mais un délai de 30 à 45
jours on va dire un délai je dirais
normal et raisonnable dans les
circonstances exceptionnelles que nous
connaissons au printemps 2021 nous
sommes sur 20 jours c'est un délai qui
est court mais ce n'est pas non plus un
délai qui est intenable j'insiste
beaucoup là-dessus je ne t'ai pas un
délai
vous savez vous demander à des
associations qui ne l'ont pas fait
puisque s'il s'agit vous avez deux cas
de figure soit les associations font
déjà
ce type d'opération sur sur les réseaux
et donc bon quoi de neuf sinon qu'on
leur donne des moyens complémentaires
c'est à dire le cas pour certains
associations auxquelles vous augmentez
les moyens pour lui permettre d'agir
plus l'entendre mais ce sont des
associations qui sont prêtes qui savent
faire peu nombreuses et qui savent faire
soit il s'agit d'association qui vont
être inventives sur le sujet qui ont des
idées peut-être
et vous dit et vous pensez que donc en
trois semaines on peut monter quelque
chose de sérieux et avec dissociation
qui qui finalement sont capables de
faire bon bah l'histoire sans aller trop
loin on peut quand même dire que
l'histoire ne donne pas tout à fait
raison à cette voix on en reste juste
aux éléments qui sont aujourd'hui
clarifiés pour tout le monde on voit
bien que c'est pas aussi simple que ça
de se lancer avec des budgets
considérables à l'échelle des
associations bien entendu des budgets
considérables sur des projets qui ne
connaissent pas sur lequel il faut tout
inventer en admettant qui s'est eu la
volonté réelle de
d'avancer donc en tout état de cause
voilà c'est un échange que je vous
demande pas d'avis vous avez donné le
vôtre mais on peut dire que c'est pas
tout à fait couronné de succès alors
maintenant vous avez eu vous l'avez
expliqué on le comprend bien vous avez
donc vous avez fait une commande
politique c'est exactement le terme qui
a fait Christian Gravel mais tout à fait
légitimement le cabinet là pour ça pour
faire de la de la commande politique à
son administration donc ça il y a pas de
il y a pas de sujet
faites une commande politique et
administration qui a un délai très court
qui nous dit-on trois mois pour pouvoir
le faire
de manière plus plus élaborée qui le
fait très rapidement et qui le fait très
rapidement auprès de gens que finalement
on pourra aller chercher une nouvelle
action parce qu'il s'agit de ça il
s'agit de faire des choses différentes
il s'agit pas de prolonger des actions
passées mais pour faire des choses
différentes et bien vous allez chercher
vous
vous cabinet je prends large bien
entendu pas partie personnelle mais vous
cabinet ministre vous allez chercher
Mohamed chefaoui qui lui-même ramène si
je puis dire l'association en question
parce qu'il faut passer par une
association parce que vous ne pouvez pas
le financer directement en tant que je
ne sais quoi expert cabinet conseil etc
vous pouvez pas donc vous le faites à
travers une association sur lequel les
précautions minimales ne sont pas prises
même si on a entendu votre position qui
est de dire votre administration vous a
sécurisé sur ce point mais c'est bien la
réalité qui ressort qui ressort du
dossier et de l'autre côté une craie une
création ex nihilo de gens qui ont un
projet qui qui défendent leurs idées qui
sont conformes à l'esprit de ce que vous
souhaitez mettre en place et sur lequel
il y a des problématiques d'autres
natures il y a du travail qui est
réalisé mais des problèmes d'autres
natures sur lesquelles on reviendra mais
d'une certaine façon en faisant un délai
court finalement on interdit en réalité
de nouveaux projets d'arriver ne peuvent
arriver que des projets qui arrivent
soit qui arrive par le haut si je puis
dire soit par vous soit par Monsieur
gravelle qui avait monté qui avait déjà
cette vision de cette association
reconstruire le commun et donc ces deux
projets
sont dans les tuyaux je simplifie et
arrive si vous voulez le fond Marianne
et il rentre voilà donc de précision à
la réalité que vous avez présenté ce
sont vos termes qu'on vous dites vous
allez chercher monsieur cifaoui dans le
vous
qui le dit pardon d'accord il dit que le
cabinet l'a appelé la joie on vérifiera
sincèrement qui nous confirme les choses
dont le vous et je vous le disais dès le
début de l'audition et si les consignes
que j'avais passé dans ces rencontres
auditions avec les uns les autres pour
alimenter la réfection collective je
souhaitais que les acteurs soient reçus
conjointement par le cabinet par
l'administration il n'y a pas de
dichotomie les choses se font ensemble
donc le vous est à vous qui est très
collectif
et quand vous dites c'est pas ce que
nous dit Monsieur Gravel
monsieur Gravel nous dit c'est pas vous
collectif monsieur Gravel nous dit
Monsieur Sifaoui nous a appelé pour nous
dire qu'il rentrait sur fond Marianne
qu'il avait vu la ministre qu'il avait
croisé le cabinet on verra avec lui
enfin l'émission mais il nous dit bien
que ce projet lui est arrivé il est pas
arrivé par le cabinet qui en discute
avec lui il est arrivé par Monsieur FIFA
oui c'est pour ça que je termine je
crois que la Formation Judiciaire
déterminera la façon le jeu se sont
passées véritablement et précisément moi
ce que je leur disposition c'est que la
consigne que j'avais passé c'est que les
acteurs soient reçus conjointement par
le cabinet par l'administration sont qui
est de dichotomie entre les uns les
autres
et le projet qui est planté par l'uepn
n'est pas un projet que le cabinet et
moi-même sommes allés chercher nous
l'avons réceptionné ce dossier il est
arrivé d'ailleurs au CPL
le point est important d'accord on va y
venir donc
c'est pas un dossier
la demande initiale de l'use US e ppm
portait vous savez sur une période
trinal d'un million et demi d'euros soit
pour 2021 635
000 euros
lors du comité de programmation qui
s'est tenu le 13 avril
en même temps que la réunion de
coordination
il avait été décidé d'accorder à cette
association une subvention de 300000
euros qui finalement le 21 mai vous
l'avez dit lors du comité de sélection
se rapportait à
355000 euros
est-ce que vous pouvez nous décrire je
vais y venir assez précisément ce qui a
motivé
les modifications donc quels étaient les
organisnements initiaux que vous dont
vous aviez éventuellement connaissance
de la ministre et de votre cabinet et ou
de votre cabinet vis-à-vis de Monsieur
Sifaoui et ce qui correspondait à la
demande initiale de 635000 euros pour
l'année 2021
pour quelle raison la subvention a été
baissée à 300.000 euros et ce qui a eu
entre le 13 avril et le 21 mai en dehors
du 22 avril où vous rencontrez monsieur
cifaoui d'autres temps d'échanges avec
qui monsieur cifaoui le Président
Monsieur Karuna Garand finalement
qu'est-ce qui a modifié
ce parcours 635 000 devenu 300 000 et
finissant à 600 à 335 000 pardon 55
alors le 13 avril en comité de
programmation sur le rapporteur on a
plusieurs dossiers qui nous sont
présentés par par l'administration dans
celui de l'ueppn pour 635.000 euros il
n'y a pas de décision de prise de
programmation et il n'y a aucun
engagement ni avant ni après qui soit
pris formulé ou indiqué a lieu ce ppm
par le cabinet et je crois aussi par
l'administration chose sont très claires
et le 13 avril
ce qui
se discutent sur s'association ce sont
les points un niveau de financement qui
est
élevé sans rapport avec nos possibilités
surtout une association aussi récente
des engagements de réalisation qui
doivent être précisé et un projet qui a
été déposé quatre jours
préalablement et qui méritent d'être
affinés entre l'administration et le el
porteur de projet donc il n'y a pas de
décision de prise pour l'USBM le 13
avril de programmation si je crois ce
que vous indiquez la semaine dernière le
prénom le superbe tailleur il ne n'est
pas connaissance de ce que une formation
de trésorerie il n'y a pas des sessions
prise
et il y aura à partir de là des échanges
avec lieu ce ppm qui seront le fait
exclusif de l'administration dans son
travail sa mission de gestion de l'appel
à projet d'examen des candidatures et le
dialogue avec les porteurs de projets et
le projet revient le 22 mai lors du
comité dit de sélection où nous
examinons les propositions que formule
de l'administration pour choisir les
lauréats du fond Marianne
effectivement la proposition qui est
faite il y a pour ce comité de sélection
une note de proposition qui est datée du
20 mai qui a été préparé par par le
cipdr je pense que vous en avez
communication sinon je la tiens à votre
à votre disposition à la fois une note
de couverture et une note plus complète
sur les horaires qui sont proposés à
validation et lors du commutation le 22
mai pour ce qui est le PPM
le cabinet votre serviteur valide la
proposition qui est faite par
l'administration sur un niveau de
financement à 355000 euros pour l'ueppm
avec une réponse qui n'est que verbale
par ailleurs à la demande de
vérification que j'ai formulé
précédemment d'accord alors il y a un
article de Libération de juin de cette
année 2023
dans lequel il est pressé que l'ancien
ministre délégué madame Schiappa aurait
présenté au journaliste un mail daté du
6 février 2021 adressée au cabinet
indiquant que la subvention accordée à
me sur cifaoui lui semblait excessive
elle aurait donc écrit précisément dans
ce mail
30000 euros de l'État ça me paraît
énorme ici est-ce que vous confirmez
cette information puisqu'il vous empêche
à pied que la date du 6 février 2021 ne
correspond pas aux dates à la
chronologie des événements tels que nous
l'avons encore
tel que nous l'avons échangé jusqu'à
maintenant est-ce que il avait donc déjà
été évoqué une subvention au moins par
la ministre antérieurement aux dates que
vous venez de nous donner alors aussi
sérieux ça me paraît totalement
impossible
il n'y a pas de projet
déposé envisagé par Monsieur behem ou
son principal porteur à cette datlage je
ne sais pas à quoi ça peut faire
référence on est sur les émotions de
rappeurs
qui font vivre une information
judiciaire
avec des investigations qui portent sur
l'ucpm qui vont conduire à des auditions
il m'est difficile de vous répondre dans
ce format de la commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur des faits qui font
l'objet de sa formation judiciaire de
manière aussi précise je m'en excuse
mais ça me paraît pas compatible
je suis je vais juste vous faire une
proposition si à l'issue de l'audition
vous êtes en capacité ce qui me paraît
possible a priori de nous communiquer
des éléments complémentaires factuels de
chronologie nous les recevrons bien
volontiers voilà
merci Monsieur la
ministre a priori devait présider le
comité de sélection ça n'a pas été le
cas finalement vous en connaissez les
raisons
il était prévu que le 22 mai
lors de la réunion du commissaire à 10
heures le 22 mai la ministre vienne
ouvrir la Réunion
et qu'il y ait une action de
communication sur la réunion de
communauté de sélection qui marque
l'arrivée à bon port de l'appel à projet
fond Marianne pour des raisons que je
n'ai plus à l'esprit la ministre n'a
j'ai pas de souvenir qu'elle soit passée
et les partis point cette réunion vont
dans son sens également la ministre n'a
pas ouvert la réunion et j'ai été amené
à la présidé du début jusqu'à la fin
pour son compte
d'accord il n'y a pas eu de gris de
notation
il y a pas eu de relevés de décision
particulière
il y avait des raisons alors nous avons
en entrée de réunion cette note datée du
20 mai produite par l'administration et
nous aurons en sortie de comité une note
du 31 mai qui
[Musique]
recense les décisions prises sur sur le
fond Marianne cette réunion
je la préside elle va durer
[Musique]
sans doute autour d'une heure et demie
et
nous allons valider presque
intégralement les propositions faites
par l'administration quant à la fois au
choix de l'orea et au niveau de
financement qu'il aurait réservé la note
préparatoire fait état de 71 dossiers
déposés
71 dossiers déposés dont
47 qui sont qui sont éligibles 24 ont
été écartés sur un critère territorial
parce que ce sont des projets qui n'ont
pas d'envergure nationale ou intérêts
plus de régions départements donc il y a
sur 60 71 aussi à déposés pardon 24 qui
sont écartés par le cipdr au stade de la
de la recevabilité je dirais
le passage de 47 dossiers éligibles à 22
qui sont présentés dans notre
préparatoire n'est pas explicité il
n'est pas explicité
je pense que ça peut tenir
à la nature des actions proposées on
souhaite avoir des actions en ligne
exclusivement
contre le discours qui ne soit pas les
actions numériques et puis ça tient
certainement au fait qu'on a
raisonnement sous enveloppes il y a 2
millions 500 000 euros disponibles pour
le contrediscours sociétal
avec les 22 dossiers qui sont priorisés
par le cipad air on est déjà au-dessus
de son offre disponible il était je
dirais de mon point de vue il était
attendu et est normal que le cipdr opère
ce travail d'instruction de présélection
et de priorisation
finalement vous avez travaillé enfin
dans un temps très contraint
je dirais même assez court
j'en conclus de ce que vous nous dites
que vous avez privilégié l'analyse
peut-être à la consignation des de
certains éléments permettant de
finalement d'expliciter les montants
enfin tous les cas de les motiver
ce qui veut dire que vous avez procédé
de quelle manière avec les associations
qui n'ont pas été retenues vous les avez
informés avec
une procédure particulière une lettre de
pas de suite une formule plus ou moins
comment dirais soit lapidaire soit très
administrative
dans une dans une démarche où les
responsabilités qui fait quoi entre
l'administration le cabinet était
clairement répartis la phase encore une
fois d'instructions et de mise en
administrative c'est le CIP d'ailleurs
le cabinet était là pour impulser puis
pour pour valider d'ailleurs ce que une
programmation de sélection PORTE un
terme qui n'est pas forcément des quad
ça a été un comité de validation à
quelques amonisations près par rapport
aux propositions faites par
l'administration que j'ai endossé à le
valider à l'issue du comité
il était nous étions convenu
de ne pas rendre public la liste de
lauréat le point a été discuté était
discuté nous avons arrêté ce choix
parce qu'il nous paraissait
pas la question parce qu'on a déjà eu ce
type de réponse la question c'est juste
de savoir si dans les réponses les
associations non retenues ont été
informés entre guillemets sous quelle
forme et sous quel délai c'est pas
d'accord alors il était nous étions
convenu qu'il y ait un courrier de la
ministre aux associations retenues
L'Oréal
ce qui était je crois fait j'en ai pas
trace dans mes archives numériques mais
je pense que ça a été fait en tout cas
plusieurs ont témoignés jusqu'à présent
dans le cadre de votre commission il
était convenu que l'administration
notifie au candidats non retenu le fait
qu'il n'était pas l'orée du fort mariage
donc l'administration sur laquelle vous
aviez aussi une influence a dû faire
mais vous n'êtes pas sûr alors le cpdr
c'est prononcé c'était prononcé pour
accorder une subvention de 100.000 euros
à une association qui en avait
d'ailleurs soluté 140 000
je dis bien le CPDS c'était prononcé
pour mais sur une décision du cabinet
donc il doit y avoir un lien avec vous
l'association n'a finalement rien obtenu
est-ce que vous pouvez
vous en expliquer les raisons est-ce que
vous avez le souvenir de cette décision
j'ai pas beaucoup d'éléments factueux à
ma disposition et je n'ai pas de
souvenir précis des échanges en comité
de sélection qui remontent à plus de
deux années
si on a une réunion d'une heure d'une
heure trente le souvenir que j'ai et les
éléments dont je dispose me permettent
de dire ou de vous redire que les
propositions faites par l'administration
ont été presque intégralement validés et
que entre les notes du préparatoire et
de sortie du comité j'ai relevé très peu
de différence
ma question à ce point est dans la
question du rapporteur en fait c'est que
comme pour tous les dossiers pour cette
association là il y a une note préalable
c'est PDR et que le 20 mai au comité de
sélection cette association est retenue
et que par contre il semblerait
que par mail d'un membre de votre
cabinet le 2 juin le financement soit
retiré
ce qui voudrait dire
pour poser la question autrement qu'il y
a eu
un comité de sélection
qu'à l'issue de ce comité de sélection
il y a
il y a une proposition qui sort
qui est faite par ce comité de sélection
et que dans les jours qui suivent
il y a encore des modifications qui se
font hors comité de sélection si je puis
dire par le cabinet
là dessus nous avons reçu un mail très
clair pour montrer qu'il y avait eu une
sortie d'une association après le comité
de sélection et alors que cette
association avait été retenue est-ce que
vous pouvez est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si c'est la réalité ou
la réalité on a les mails bon
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça c'est à
dire l'idée que finalement il y a un
appel à projet on en a parlé il y a un
comité de sélection on en a parlé mais
que le comité de sélection finalement
n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga et n'est
pas la fin de l'histoire et que dans les
jours qui suivent il y a encore des
modifications sur ce dossier est-ce que
vous pouvez nous confirmer ce point
alors
en comité de sélection le 22 mai nous
entrons en réunion avec une note du
célibataire qui propose 15 dossiers qui
propose 15 dossiers à à validation
et qui en annexe 7 autres qui sont qui
sont
[Musique]
proposés
pour pour discussion
sur ces sept projets sur les 15
projetsalistes principales je crois
qu'on comité de sélection nous les
validons
presque tous à l'exception d'un seul qui
sera capable après discussion parce
qu'il est considéré que les actions
proposées sont des actions qui sont
intéressantes pertinentes les porteurs
du projet sont par ailleurs d'une grande
qualité on est sur des interventions en
milieu scolaire qui ne sont pas des
actions de conditions numériques cette
action est écartée pour cette région là
sur les 7 associations qui figurent dans
l'annexe et donc ils font une discussion
particulière en comité de sélection il y
en a trois qui vont être retenues
en tant que lauréat à des niveaux de
financement qui sont inférieurs à ce qui
était demandé pour des raisons
d'enveloppes budgétaires
il y a une association
qui de cette quatrième association de la
liste annexe qui n'est donc pas proposé
par le cipdr en financement au titre du
fond Brian on n'est pas dans liste
principale et qui dans l'échange qu'on
peut avoir au cours du comité puisque
c'est un échange mais la collégialité
je pose des questions mes collaborateurs
aussi les le cipdr il y a un secrétaire
général et ses collaborateurs il y a une
discussion collective et sur cette
association de vous citer avec une
demande à 140.000 euros le comité de
sélection dans les conclusions que Jean
dresse à l'issue du comité est retenu
pour un montant de 100.000 euros
cette liste de lauréats naturellement je
rencontre à la ministre pour lui faire
part des décisions qui sont envisagées
et nous avons sur cette association
une réserve de la de la ministre en
raison d'un historique de relations
assez anciens et par ailleurs dans les
jours qui précèdent ou qui suivent à la
fin du mois de mai
une mise en cause par WordPress
de d'un membre de l'association
vis-à-vis de la ministre ce qui
conditionnit sur ce point qui était un
point de discussion important en comité
de sélection et qui relevait d'une d'un
arbitrage ou d'une confirmation par la
mite nous avons une décision de
non-sélections sur cette association
donc il y a bien eu sur les décisions
arrêtant comme outil sélection pour l'un
de ces lauréat
une affirmation par la ministre
dans votre développement je puisque au
début vous nous avez dit non je sais pas
trop je vois pas puis
vous vous avez dit qu'il y avait un
problème de d'enveloppe pour faire
rentrer dans le budget mais moi je vois
pas de problème puisque il y a pas pu
avoir dans tous les cas ce motif puisque
l'enveloppe totale initial n'a pas été
consommé donc je veux juste être sûr de
qu'il y a pas de méprise dans les
éléments d'appréciation dans les motifs
que vous venez d'évoquer alors 2.500000
euros c'est le montant qui est
consacré aux actions de contre discours
numérique
et au fond Marianne il y a
une association qui va être retenue
avant le lancement du fond Marianne sur
un projet déposé depuis déjà plusieurs
mois un projet qui est prêt à démarrer
et qui va être financé sur une partie
des crédits de format on est sur le
contre discours numérique sociétal 2
millions 500 000 euros 2 millions seront
attribués dans le cadre de l'appel
approché du fond Marianne et 500 000
euros l'auront été hors appel à projet
et avant lancement de l'appel à projet
pour une association qui porte un projet
très important
et prêt à démarrer alors j'ai
une avant dernière question là j'ai un
vrai problème puisque dans le rapport de
là vous venez d'évoquer une question que
vous aviez évoqué avec la ministre qui a
tranché
et d'un rapport de l'IGA il est
mentionné que
la ministre délégué
ce serait facile du processus une fois
passé
le lancement de l'appel à projet le 20
avril vous venez de dire que le 22 mai
à l'issue du comité de sélection vous
avez eu une discussion et d'ailleurs une
décision de la ministre ou venez de le
dire donc c'est en contradiction je le
porte à votre connaissance si vous
souhaitez vous exprimer évidemment vous
pouvez le faire avec les éléments
qui sont portés au compte-rendu de du
rapport de l'igéa
la ministre
a lancé le fond Marianne le 20 avril
elle à l'occasion d'une d'un entretien
et d'une interview en presse le jour où
l'appel à projet est lancé par ailleurs
par le CPD de manière formelle et
administrative la ministre se tient
effectivement à l'écart du processus
elle ne rencontre pas de porteurs de
projet elle ne participent pas au comité
de sélection le 22 mai elle nous donne
pas d'instruction
particulière
collectives ou individuels sur le choix
des lauréats et il y a en communauté de
sélection cette discussion qui est une
discussion
importante sur l'association que vous
avez cité puisque l'administration ne
propose pas de la financer
et que en sortie de comité en tant que
président du la Réunion l'association on
envisage de la financier donc il y a
bien un point de discussion particulier
sur cette association qui n'est pas
proposée par l'administration
spontanément que le comité soit
président
et c'est un point que je porte à
l'arbitrage de la ministre
et sur ce point là elle fait connaître
son arbitrage qui est un arbitrage
défavorable
ma dernière question
certaines associations donc ont vu vous
l'avez dit leur subventions réduites
vous avez évoqué une il y a une
association bibliothèque sans frontières
qui
a obtenu donc à peu près la moitié de ce
qu'elle sollicitait 70 000 euros alors
qu'elle se listait 130 000 je mets ça en
rapport avec
la subvention dont elle avait bénéficié
l'année antérieure qui était de 140 000
euros vous avez
des quelques éléments pour éclairer
notre lanterne
alors à mon niveau sur un porteur
clairement non j'étais dans un une
approche on va dire stratégie j'entre à
ce comité avec une préparatoire qui
donne des éléments pas forcément tout
l'historique et nous appuyons sur
l'administration pour faire ce travail
là je rappelle c'est important nous
avions donc créé l'unité de contredit
sous la républicain au sein du cipdr fin
2020 en avril 2021 l'unité compte 15
agents et nous faisons confiance à notre
administration dans des relations de
confiance et alors que nous avons veillé
à ce qu'elle soit renforcée pour faire
ce travail d'instruction de priorisation
ce qu'elle a fait a priori
Alma qui est une association bien connue
avec
laquelle les le système institutionnel
travail n'a finalement pas été
comptabilisé dans le fond mariage
quand bien même plusieurs documents
indiquent et attestent dans un je dirais
dans un premier temps qu'elle a été
retenue dans le cadre de du fond vous
avez une explication sur ce revirement
alors l'association que vous avez cité
dans les documents qui vous ont été
communiqués pour le comité de sélection
il est je crois à mentionner
expressément que
la décision a été prise
[Musique]
préalablement et hors appel à projet et
le 13 avril en comité de programmation
me semble-t-il on est sur un projet qui
était déposé je crois en début d'année
début février auprès du cipdr un projet
de médias en ligne en direction
des jeunes dans les dans les quartiers
populaires
un projet très travaillé moi j'ai eu
l'occasion bien avant c'était à
l'automne 2020 de recevoir le directeur
de l'association et plusieurs de ses
collaborateurs
avec le secrétaire et puis du cabinet
pour que le projet ne soit présenté le
projet paraissait très ambitieux et
pertinent il est déposé en demande de
subvention début février et nous
décidons de le valider les prêts à
démarrer nous le validons aura pas la
projet début avril
grâce au crédit que nous ont pu
mobiliser pour le contreditours sociétal
c'est à dire de mieux 500 000 euros on
est hors appel à projet ce qui montre
bien qu'il y a bien deux phases
distinctes la phase de grains et Grey il
y a une association qui sera choisie
dans cette phase là sur un projet déposé
très entraînement aux autres puis une
phase d'appel à projet sur laquelle
seront envoyés tous les autres projets
déposés plus précocément ou après des
rencontres avec le cabinet d'accord ce
qui doit vous le dire ce qui n'a pas
empêché la ministre d'adresser
un courrier de félicitations à cette
association
qu'elle a signé
avec une mention manuscrite précisant
quel était lauréate de du fond Marianne
oui il y a pu y avoir une effectivement
c'est une norme matériel ou une
confusion qui s'explique par le fait
qu'on est sur le contre discours
numérique on est sur
ce budget de 1500 000 euros
et l'association que vous avez cité
et financer grâce à ces crédits-là et
sera suivi comme les 17 lauréat du fond
Marianne de manière plus importante
quant aux réalisations qu'elle fera
vous dites c'est une confusion je dirais
de manière permettez-moi de dire c'est
pour le moins particulièrement confus
dans le dans le fonctionnement
une dernière question
est-ce que puisque ça a été évoqué il y
a quand même deux associations
qui sont pointés une première l'uspm qui
a un budget de fonctionnement habituel
relativement faible qui n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec la cause
nationale que vous mettez en œuvre au
travers du fond Marianne qui voilà d'un
budget annuel de 50.000 euros de
fonctionnement
sollicitent un million cinq sur trois
ans on l'a évoqué une deuxième qui n'a
pas d'existence propre qui se crée et à
laquelle
des fonds importants de 300.000 euros
sont
vont être accordés je dirais dans le
comité puisque vous évoquez la rigueur
du comité de sélection
vous pensez que rien n'a échappé à votre
la vigilance et à la rigueur du travail
tant de l'administration que du cabinet
alors
aujourd'hui la réponse
est claire au vu du rapport LGA publié
hier soir au vu de ce que l'on sait la
réponse est claire
il y a deux ans dans le contexte que
vous connaissez d'urgence attentats
mobilisation générale nous avions des
projet qui était présenté qui ont été
instruits appréciés par une
administration
professionnelle renforcée spécifiquement
pour eux pour cela et quand on prend ses
décisions lors du sélection le 22 mai on
le fait avec un niveau de sécurité
pour ce qui est du cabinet qui est un
niveau
important élevé alors nonobstant nous
l'obstant monsieur le rapporteur nous
allons tenir alors que c'est pas
forcément d'ailleurs
la mission du cabinet a opéré un suivi
précis à opérer un suivi de l'action de
ces de ce lauréat et je vais provoquer
une réunion de suivi le 14 décembre donc
six mois après la sélection des projets
pour regarder vérifier
puisque j'entends ce que vous dites un
niveau élevé de sécurité mais vous dire
juste avant regarder fait maintenant on
s'aperçoit que
il y a pour le moins
une marge une erreur ce que je veux
quand même vous dire à nos collègues a
eu l'occasion lors d'une audition
présente de rappeler que
dans le fonctionnement habituel des
associations des attributions de
subventions notamment lorsqu'elles
sollicitent les collectivités parfois
pour des montants de quelques centaines
d'euros pour demande des éléments de
bilan et là vous nous dites avec comment
dirais-je gravité au regard de l'urgence
une association qui n'a pas d'existence
propre
présente une demande de 300.000 euros
urgence de la situation frapper fort
association en cours de création contre
discours républicain on il y a on
délivre comment dirais-je un bon attiré
je veux dire comme ça de 300.000 euros
et il y a pas plus de questions au
regard de la gravité et de la situation
de son importance et des du sérieux du
comité de sélection
je m'appuie dans la fonction qui était
la mienne à l'époque sur le travail et
les propositions qui sont
faits par l'administration
je n'ai que ces éléments là
d'appréciation
clairement
Monsieur le Préfet simplement conclure
cette phase
on n'arrive pas à être très convaincu
vous le sentez
sur sur ce sujet là et on arrive pas à
être convaincu pourquoi parce que en
aucun cas le fond Marianne n'est une
réponse appropriée à un risque
d'attentat c'est une action
que l'on peut imaginer qui peut avoir du
sens
mais qui est une action de long terme et
qui se construit dans le long terme avec
une idée de profiter finalement d'un
reste à réaliser pour démarrer une
action mais avec l'idée d'ailleurs c'est
même dans les objectifs dans les
objectifs dans le cahier des charges il
y a l'idée qu'il faut trouver des
cofinancements la notion est évoquée
clairement et co-financement pour
pouvoir perdurer faire perdre du respect
d'action dans le temps on le comprend
bien et donc sa sœur à cette question de
vitesse non la question de la vitesse
c'est la question de la rapidité de la
communication
c'est c'est tout le problème de la
nécessité supposée de devoir répondre
vite à l'opinion publique sur des sujets
aussi importants et aussi graves et
quand on regarde finalement
quand on regarde les choses entre
finalement la façon dont l'appel à
projet c'est fait la façon dont on a
préparé un amour quelques associations y
compris des créations pour pouvoir
répondre à cet appel de à cet appel à
projet quand on voit comment se fait la
sélection quand on voit qu'après
finalement
la réunion de sélection les choses
bougent encore qu'il y a des
associations qui sont retirées que
d'autres voient leur niveau BC etc
l'ensemble de tout ça permet de dire que
la remarque de l'IGA l'appel à projet
n'a été ni transparent ni équitable
reste d'actualité et je pense qu'il
qu'à l'avenir il faudra tirer de cette
expérience ce qui s'est fait là quelques
règles pour l'avenir je viens d'un mot
il est maintenant tard je viens d'un mot
sur le suivi de la réalisation des
projets
d'abord mais vous avez déjà ouvert cette
voie sur l'idée que le cabinet avait
participé au suivi de la réalisation des
projets c'est une question qui était qui
était posée qui n'apparaît pas
directement dans le dossier et est-ce
que finalement la procédure de suivi
était la même que pour les autres
subventions FIP et
je pense peut-être avant de précisément
votre question
d'apporter
une remarque sur
le constat qui est posé par rapport aux
gens que vous avez que vous avez cité il
transport en équitable j'ai pas d'Asie
personnelle je puisse faire remarquer
que concrètement sur le
contredischronique nous avions deux
possibilités l'appel à projet ou le gré
à gré et que entre les deux la procédure
qui présente un niveau de transparence
et d'équité
plus favorable c'est l'appel approche
vous l'avez bien expliqué vous aurez le
plus procédé différemment et faire de
gras gré
nous n'aurions pas ces critiques là
aujourd'hui qui sont fondées très simple
pour certaines mais nous aurions pu
faire différemment et le fait de choisir
l'appel à projet n'a pas été fait pour
refuser la transparence et l'équité bien
au contraire
on peut bien sûr discuter ensuite du
résultat et je suis là pour ça oui mais
là c'est la notion de est-ce qu'il y
aurait une intention de c'est parce que
nous indiquons nous sommes factuels
simplement nous parlons pas d'intention
de pas sur ce registre
sur la question donc
de la procédure de suivi est-ce qu'elle
est identique à celle du FIP et
classique sur le suivi on est sur une
phase qui relève de la responsabilité
de l'administration classiquement à la
fois pour formaliser une décision de
financement via un acte attributif
arrêté ou convention attributive de
subventions
en respectant les règles qui sont
prévues à cet effet le cas échéant en
revenant vers le cabinet s'il y a des
difficultés ou des écarts ou des
modifications à apporter très
classiquement et puis un suivi sur
l'impact on est sur une action publique
qui est nouvelle encore une fois
des montants qui sont significatifs pour
certains
un besoin de démontrer l'impact de ces
nouvelles actions et donc contrairement
à ce que nous faisons pour les personnes
nationaux classiques le cabinet demande
au cipdr avec une tête de contredours
nouvellement créé d'assurer un suivi un
suivi
fin un suivi des réalisations et c'est
dans ce contexte là que je provoque une
réunion de suivi le 14 décembre
2021 qui sera pressé d'une autre
préparatoire produite par le site du 13
je pense que vous l'avez sinon je peux
tout simplement vous la vous la
communiquer et cette note comme les
échanges qui ont lieu en comité enfin
réunion de suivi
ne laisse apparaître ne laisse pas
apparaître d'alerte
ou de discuter particulière la tonalité
est positive
y compris sur l'ueppm donc on sera le
commun il est fait mention d'un décalage
pour certaines associations dont
celle-ci
du calendrier de réalisation qu'on peut
comprendre à ce stade de six mois après
là les décisions en comité de sélection
et il ne met pas fait état de
difficultés où ils ont comment d'alerte
sur l'action des 17 lorés du fond Bryan
plus l'association qui est si rattachée
comme sur le rapporteur
et ce sera le cas jusqu'à mon départ du
cabinet début 2022 où je n'aurai pas
d'alerte ni en interne ni venant de
l'extérieur sur des difficultés et
l'action des lorra du fond moyen je
crois que ça va être le cas jusqu'au
terme du mandat de maladi Schiappa au
ministère matériaux
merci
[Musique]
alors vous avez écouté j'imagine où vous
avez relu les auditions de certaines
associations
qui ont un site qui avait qui nous ont
dit des choses donc qui sont compliquées
toujours sur le lien entre un ministère
et des associations par rapport à une
subvention surtout que c'est subventions
on l'a vu en fait était la totalité quoi
des projets elles ont été montées
souvent ça a été des projets montés avec
l'idée qu'il y avait des co-financeurs
qui pouvaient être publiques ou privés
dans la réalité les co-financeurs on
peut le comprendre d'ailleurs c'est
compliqué à trouver sur ces thèmes là et
donc du coup c'est 100% ministère de
l'intérieur mais c'est on a des phrases
du type
on ne souhaite pas être des on ne peut
pas être considéré comme des
prestataires de services du ministère de
l'intérieur alors cette relation entre
ce qui paye au monde et
et l'autonomie d'un système associatif
ça paraît assez fin à toucher
un commentaire
oui
notamment dans le suivi je veux dire la
relation du coup le suivi porte sur quoi
s'y porte pas sur en dehors de l'aspect
financier on oublie il y a un contrôleur
il est là pour vérifier les factures etc
ça on oublie donc parlons du contrôle de
l'exécution
comment vous voyez un contrôle
d'exécution
utile vous n'êtes pas alerté d'ailleurs
par quoi que ce soit alors qu'il y a des
choses à dire c'est au moins on le
découvre aujourd'hui
alors on n'est pas sur une prestation de
service
c'est très important un projet
associatif dont les termes et les
engagements n'ont pas été
dictées ou commander par
l'administration ou le ministère très
important on est sur un projet
associatif en réponse à un appel à
projet qui fixe des grands objectifs un
cadre mais le projet se suivit de
l'association
dans cette relation entre l'association
et l'administration ou le ministère moi
ce qui me paraît important c'est que il
y a des engagements qui soient précis de
réalisation un qu'on sache ce qu'on
finance et c'est sur ces éléments là
même s'ils sont succinctement présentés
en comédie de sélection on va se
prononcer quand au choix de le rat au
niveau de financement
après on est aussi sur quelques
principes généraux qui valent sans qu'on
ait besoin de les préciser et dans ces
principes euros il y a la neutralité
la partialité
de l'action publique et il n'est pas
concevable c'est une ligne rouge absolue
que sur fonds publics on puisse
soutien des actions qui s'insèrent dans
le débat politique ou démocratique je
fais référence c'est ce qui est
reprochait à une association parmi 17 du
fond Marianne très clairement c'est une
ligne rouge absolue que nous avons fixée
et qui vaut dans tous les cas de manière
générale de ne pas intervenir avec le
contrediscours républicain dans le champ
électoral ou démocratique et ça vaut
pourquoi juste pourquoi n'y a-t-il alors
qu'il y a des
signalements en tout cas des
interrogations au niveau du cpdr je ne
sais pas si elles sont remontées jusqu'à
vous vous allez nous le dire mais
pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas une mise en
garde
autre chorale je veux dire on a une
relation contractuelle avec une
association il y a une difficulté de
cette nature qui apparaît vous en citer
une on écrit c'est même totalement je
veux dire c'est immédiat on écrit on
relate le problème et on demande une
réponse voilà bon pourquoi il y a rien
on a l'impression que tout glisse vous
voyez ce que je veux dire on peut on
peut éventuellement pointer des choses
encore que les associations en question
ne l'ont pas même bien entendu ou voilà
mais en plus on ne leur écrit pas
et donc aujourd'hui quand on leur dit
mais attendez
les gens tombent
de la chaise
alors ça peut être effectivement compris
comme une règle générale de bon sens ça
de ce point de vue là je suis d'accord
avec vous mais lorsqu'on constate un
dysfonctionnement et qu'on est financeur
est-ce que ça mérite pas
un petit écrit
une règle générale
qui vaut absolument pour
l'administration et donc pour nos
services et pour le cipdr MT contre le
discours pas d'interférence et c'est
important on est sur un champ de contre
le discours qui est un champ
qui relève du débat public qui peut
facilement entrer en résonance avec le
débat politique donc on est sur un champ
où la ligne rouge c'est de ne pas
prendre pas à des discussions des débats
de nature et électorale ou démocratiques
et donc pourquoi on écrit pas ça je me
serais pas vous le dire moi je n'ai pas
d'alerte particulière lorsque je suis en
responsabilité de cette nature une
d'ailleurs d'aucune autre je crois qu'il
n'y en aura pas non plus
jusqu'à ce que la ministre délégué
quitte ce ministère délégué au mois
d'avril ou mai 2022 mais ce sont des
débordements qui ne paraissaient sans
réaction et d'ailleurs je crois qu'il y
a des tu crois qu'il y a eu des
réactions me semble-t-il si j'ai bien
écouté les auditions des précédentes
oui
c'est pas il y a pas le même son si vous
voulez côté associatif et côté
cpdr mais bon nous verrons poursuivons
parce que leur leur avance et donc il
faut il faut conclure et puis pour tous
si je puis dire donc
on lance alors avec tambour et trompette
sur votre sur votre sujet mais il peut y
avoir une vérification à faire de notre
point de vue mais elle n'a pas lieu
c'est peut-être novembre 21 quand même
un peu de truc mais je ne sais pas donc
on va on va vérifier ce point de mais en
tout cas je peux constater sans même
parler de cette réunion
c'est que il n'y a plus de communication
sur le fond mariage plus de son plus
d'image si je puis dire sur est-ce que
on a des comment les choses se mettent
en place quel résultat enfin on peut
imaginer que quand on lance une idée
forte par rapport à un événement
monstrueux par ailleurs et qui reste
dans les mémoires de tous pour ça que
c'est pour ça que cette affaire elles
font Marianne
est tellement sensible c'est que elle
porte sur un sujet enfin il y a un lien
qui est fait entre un sujet extrêmement
grave et le format et donc donc il y a
une attention à ce qui se passe et là
plus de son plus d'image sur ce sujet
plus de médiatisation
plus de résultats c'est bien 2021 comme
vous l'imaginiez on me corrige sur un
instant et donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi n'en
parle plus
est-ce que finalement vous avez enfin je
vais pas répondre à votre place
je pourrais pas me prononcer sur ce qui
s'est passé après mon départ je le
comprends bien on est en novembre 21
et mon arrivée
sur le fond Marianne une initiative une
impulsion qui a été donnée par la
ministre avec des projets
nombreux qui ont été déposés
par des associations qui étaient déjà
connues d'autres qui n'étaient pas du
tout une grande diversité et un grand
pluralisme d'acteurs
nous n'avons pas
pu avec les lauréats
organisé
puisque cela d'initiative ou de
communication parce qu'on a tenu à
protéger ne pas exposer ses lauréat il y
a ne pas les marquer d'un soutien de
l'État pour l'électricité de leur action
donc il y a pas eu de communication
particulière et l'objectif de fond ça
reste sur une action publique qui se met
en place nouvellement de l'inscrire dans
la durée
de faire en sorte que cette action
s'inscrire dans la durée et se pérennise
et ce normalisent donc le fond moyen
c'est un fond d'impulsion d'amorçage en
2021 et l'enjeu était qu'à compter 2022
est né suivantes ces actions de
contreditours numérique fassent partie
des actions conventionnelles de droit
commun soutenu par l'administration
ministère intérieur
très bien vous nous avez pas vous
répondre que le président au-delà de mon
départ sur ce qui a je comprends bien je
comprends mais vous nous avez répondu
sur le fait que vous n'aviez pas été
alerté jusqu'à votre départ de problèmes
particuliers notamment sur les deux
associations question mais peut-être
éventuellement sur d'autres je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur
peut-être une petite première remarque
sur le sujet de la de la communication
rien d'empêcher
de faire comment dirais-je des actions
de communication puisqu'elles
s'inscrivait dans l'appel à projet du
fond Marianne
et je veux revenir sur pour être bien
sûr
de la clarification du sujet entre le
cipdr le cabinet sous votre autorité et
la ministre vous confirmez bien que
c'est le cpdr qui a préparé l'ensemble
car aucun moment le cabinet n'est
intervenu sur la préparation et je
dirais sur le le les associations qui
ont fait partie du de la sélection qui a
été proposée le dans le comité du 22 mai
c'est bien ça on est sur répartition
avec un cabinet qui pour le compte de la
ministre impulse
répercute la commande ministérielle va
en comité de sélection validé
pour certaines une administration qui
réceptionne les dossiers de demande de
subvention les instruits échanges avec
les porteurs de projet priorise et
propose un niveau de financement pour
mettre sélection il y a quand même donc
il y a une zone j'ai envie de dire il y
a une zone de flou entre la publication
définitive et le comité dit de sélection
dont vous avez dit mais vous n'êtes pas
le seul à l'avoir dit qu'il était un
comité de validation
et en fait ensuite il y a quand même
comment dirais-je
une intervention politique vous en avez
évoqué une deux trois enfin alors je
sais pas si c'est à chaque fois la
ministre parce qu'entre les montants qui
sont pas ceux qui sont plus faibles que
se demander
où
finalement une proposition validée non
retenue après change avec la ministre
si vous avez je dirais des dernières des
derniers éléments
précis à nous communiquer soit tout de
suite soit par écrit je vous dis nous
serons preneurs enfin nous sommes
preneurs parce qu'on
a quand même la volonté d'avoir une
présentation et pour je pense que pour
tout le monde et notamment au regard de
l'action publique
et je le dis
je pense que on a qu'à ma climat
politique qui est lourd on est sur un
fait Claude Raynal l'a déjà dit on le
dit régulièrement le fait générateur est
quand même un acte d'une barbarie son
nom des annonces fortes sur des valeurs
fortes et malheureusement aujourd'hui
dans ce qu'on est amené à examiner
montre qu'il y a tout à l'heure c'est
pour le moins confus je vais pas aller
plus loin parce que il s'agit pas de
tirer activement de conclusion
merci c'est vrai que l'absence de
formalisation des échanges et des
décisions dans des documents
rédiger et signé et pénalisant pour
retranscrire le processus et différentes
étapes et les décisions prises c'est une
vraie difficulté
et l'essentiel de ce qui vous est
rapporté repose sur le témoignages les
souvenirs les échanges entre les uns et
les autres c'est pas toujours toujours
simple ce qui fait fois me semble-t-il
ce sont les décisions qui ont été prises
et formalisées dans les actes
attributifs
de subventions par l'administration
après échange avec le cabinet de la de
la ministre je confirme ce que je vous
ai dit précédemment le comité de
sélection a pour l'essentiel valider les
propositions faites par l'administration
après instruction sur dossier des vrais
dossiers déposés par les porteurs de
projets il y a eu quelques amies
en comité de sélection
sur la liste complémentaire et il y a eu
un dossier que vous avez évoqué de la
liste complémentaire que le comme titre
sélection a remis en liste principale et
qui a été portée la brioche de la
ministre sur ce seul dossier là c'est ce
que je peux vous dire et c'est ce que
j'ai réussi à retracer après beaucoup de
recherches après beaucoup de recherches
et de consultation des uns des autres
pour comprendre précisé
mais oui je crois que
on va évidemment se maintenir là nous
avons deux questions des collègues on va
les prendre et une réponse très brève et
des questions brèves Isabelle briquet
puis philippe Dominati non
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Préfet vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure il y a eu 71 dossiers une
sélection très importante certaines
associations écartées travaillaient déjà
de longue date avec le cipdr si monsieur
cifaoui était connu du Cid PDR
l'usée ppm était inconnue par contre
du Cid PPE du Cid
r je sais plus
donc n'avait visiblement jamais fait de
demande de subvention mais de n'importe
quel subvention subventions quelle
qu'elle puisse être ces dernières années
et avait un budget cela a été dit un
budget moyen de 50 000 euros vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure qu'il s'agit bien
de projets associatifs
et lors des échanges évoqués aussi à
l'instant entre monsieur Sifaoui et le
cabinet échange particulier puisque ça
n'a pas été le cas pour d'autres
associations le fait que l'uppppm
ne travaillez pas sur le sujet traité
demande en première intention une
subvention ce que ça a été dit tout à
l'heure ça a été réduit cette subvention
était réduite par la suite mais faisons
12 fois sont son budget
n'a pas soulevé quelques interrogation
que ce soit de la part du du cabinet
merci
philippe Dominati vous prendrez les deux
questions pour conclure je voulais
compléter la question que poser le
rapporteur général parce qu'il y a cette
notion de cabinet mais je croyais que le
cabinet était assez léger dans
l'organisation et par les décrets du
Premier ministre alors ça concerne
combien de personnes parce que c'est une
notion un peu collective
et j'aimerais savoir combien de
personnes au cabinet s'occupaient du
fond Marianne parce que si c'est 15
personnes c'est évidemment pas la même
chose que de deux trois décideurs et
deuxièmement il y a le relationnel
effectivement dans le fonctionnement
d'un cabinet tout le monde le sait qu'il
y a entre l'autorité ministérielle et la
délégation que l'on fournit au cabinet
et quelle est cette part comme le
souligner le rapporteur général qui a
été faite on a eu des exemples dans le
passé au ministère des Finances ou le
directeur de cabinet était investi de
pouvoir pour mieux
les plages du ministre pour prendre des
décisions
c'est une question qui mériterait d'être
un petit peu souligné monsieur le
président
le cabinet a reçu
la personne qui a été citée à plusieurs
reprises et non pas l'association
ce n'est que la personne qu'elle sait
plusieurs bus qui a été reçue par le
cabinet
cette personne là à plusieurs reprises
ce n'est pas lieu ce ppm
qui ne sera pas reçu au cabinet
et avec laquelle il n'y aura pas de
relation particulière qu'elle soit
téléphonique par mail ou autre de la
part du cabinet et quand je reçois le 22
avril
la personne qui était cité pour le
compte de la ministre c'est bien la
personne que je reçois et pas
l'association voilà l'association l'uppm
elle n'a pas été reçue elle a été gérée
intégralement par l'administration à
partir du dépôt demande de subventions
et cette demande
je ne rends pas pour argent comptant
puisque vous avez rappelé le montant qui
était demandé initialement 635000 euros
et que
dès la première représentation de ce
projet donc le 13 avril en comité de
programmation on marque des réserves
immédiatement
on demande à ce que le projet soit
affiné donc revu avec le porteur de
projet
au vu d'engagement qui peuvent être pris
et au vu de vérification opérée sur le
statut de l'association donc vis-à-vis
de cette association on a été dans une
approche qui était une approche
rationnelle
prudente et on a parlé pour argent
comptant ce qui était demandé par
l'association en question très
clairement et ensuite c'était géré par
l'administration
pour répondre à la question de monsieur
le sénateur
sur combien de personnes au cabinet est
en charge du fond Marianne
aucune spécifiquement il n'est pas un
conseiller pour Marianne du tout
c'est un sujet le contrediscours qui
était suivi en termes de portefeuille de
compétences des uns des autres par le
conseiller spécial de la ministre sur
une partie de son temps partie très
minoritaire et par le conseiller
prévention de la délinquance c'est déjà
très à la citoyenneté et promotion de la
citoyenneté sur une partie aussi très
minérale de son temps donc deux
conseillers principalement à mes côtés
c'était pas un sujet secondaire ou
périphérique du tout pour les raisons
qui ont été rappelées et j'attacher une
égale importance à tous les sujets tous
les chantiers que la ministre avait en
responsabilité
mais c'est
un chantier qui une fois passé la phase
d'impulsion et la validation relevée
pour l'essentiel de mission
administrative de préparation et
d'exécution
et quant à la porte de délégation
question effectivement centrale un parti
dans les cabinets ministériels je dirais
que ces fonctions
ces fonctions des relations de confiance
entre le ou la ministre et son sa
directeur de cabinet j'avais
[Musique]
la mise pourra sans doute vous
l’indiquer j'avais au sein du cabinet
une délégation de signature j'étais le
seul en bénéficier et donc j'étais le
seul collaborateur qui était fondé à
engager
vis-à-vis de l'administration vis-à-vis
des tiers des décisions de la ministre
et je rendais compte bien évidemment de
toutes les décisions importantes de
manière régulière permanente à la
ministre
pour ce que j'étais amené à dire ou à
faire en son nom
merci merci Monsieur le Préfet nous
avons passé ensemble deux heures et
demie
ce qui nous a permis je crois de voir
effectivement l'ensemble des points des
sujets qui peuvent question dans ce fond
Marianne merci encore merci monsieur